e
well good morning everybody uh hope
everybody had a good weekend at least we
didn't get a whole lot of rain um today
we have three bills in schedule for the
morning which are to be heard and then
we will be exec in the afternoon so I'd
like to get right into the first Bild
which we have on the docket for today
today and that's Senate Bill 596 596 is
relative to the definition of disability
or special needs under the child care
scholarship
program there's been some concern of why
did education get this vers another
committee here in the house side it was
handed to us so very very late and it is
an early bill it would cost a lot of
issues if it been vacated to a we've
already vacated several BS this year but
we had time to do it and consider it we
have had no time to deal it so we are
going to address this I know Senate Ed
addressed it so I'd like to welcome uh
to present the bill it won't be the
senator right it' be uh Phil uh wench
Senator uh hello Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Phil Tetro and I'm senator rard
legislative Aid Senator richardi wishes
she could be here today to introduce
this important piece of legislation but
she had a prior commitment to an event
within her District nevertheless I'm
here to speak on the importance of sp sp
596 Early Childhood stakeholders came to
Senator rardy this past fall asking for
help to address the issue of
differential payment access for Children
at Risk of of Developmental
disability while our existing Child Care
framework provides necessary support for
children with diagnosed disabilities it
unfortunately leaves behind those at the
cusp of De developmental challenges
those not yet diagnosed but showing
clear signs of being at
risk these are children who show clear
delays in motor function speech
cognitive play and social emotional
development children who often later
receive formal diagnosises for autism
attention deficit disorder and other
learning uh impartment uh the evidence
is clear the earlier we identify
intervene and support children who are
at risk for developmental delay the
greater the likelihood the child is to
is later able to catch up academically
to their peers to address this issue
Senator richardi proposed SB 596 to
expand the definition of disability
within our child care scholarship
program Advocates working with DHHS
proposed an amendment to S SP 596 which
did not change the intent of s SP 596
but more efficiently outlin the process
necessary to strengthen the differential
pain the amended version of s SP 596
would enable DHHS to enter rul making to
Define this class of children and ensure
the definition includes not only
children with diagnosed delay uh but
those at high risk it would enable DHHS
to work with experts and Advocates to
identify the proper screening tools and
verification needed to ensure eligible
children can get the support they need
childcare differential payments as it
currently exists is grossly
underutilized by by providers in part
because so few children can demonstrate
a diagnosable disability when they're
under the age of 3 or four this policy
change is not only about supporting
children but also about bolstering our
child care providers by enabling access
to differential payments for atrisk
children we can provide centers with the
necessary resources to maintain
appropriate ratios and offer high
quality Care thereby expanding access to
child care for All Families across our
state senator rard has heard time and
time again of Provider suppressing
ratios in classrooms because they have a
few children requiring additional
support with access to differential
payment centers uh differential payment
centers will be able to bring in some
additional staff capacity and classroom
support to assist in providing these
children with the Hands-On learning
support they need to be
successful in conclusion this bill
represents a strategic evidence informed
approach to enhancing our child care
system
it ensures that children particularly
those at risk of Developmental delays
receive the support they need during
their most formative
years I urge the members of this
committee to support this vital
legislation for the well-being of the
children and the future of our state
thank you for your time and
consideration and I am happy to pass
along any of your questions to Senator
rardy thank you very much Phil do you
have that's written testimony that you
read from the senator yes do you have a
copy of that um I do not have a copy
yeah if you could provide us a copy
we'll enter that right into to the
record are there any
questions yes represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here to introduce this um I
wanted to ask a question based on the
portion that
identifies um who would be included
under the definition of dis disability
which is uh 2A here um and it says any
child who displays or is at risk for
delayed social or emotional development
given the Upp in of of children and the
things any the things that can happen to
a child isn't any child potentially at
risk for delayed depending on what
happens to them uh thank you for the
question representative uh I'm happy to
pass that question along to Senator
rardy but I know there's individuals
behind me that can speak further on yes
we we do have people behind that can
speak to this uh Phil's just presenting
on behalf of the
senator nothing else thank you very much
thank you
i' like to invite Rebecca
up and Rebecca is the one with all the
answers thank you could you introduce
yourself please sure good morning
honorable chair and members of the
committee my name is Rebecca volovski
and I'm the child and family policy
director at new Futures new Futures is a
nonpartisan nonprofit organization
working to improve the health and
wellbeing of New Hampshire's residents
through policy change and I focus on our
tiniest residents our children as New
Hampshire's authorized kids count
organization new futur also advocates
for databased policies to support
granted State families I'm here today to
speak in favor of Senate Bill 596 as
it's an important bill in our state's
effort to address and alleviate the
child care crisis Phil did a really good
job introducing this bill so I'm just
going to highlight a couple of points
number one as mentioned uh this bill
does not um address anything relative to
K through 12 education it is primarily
and solely focused on our child care
scholarship program which is supported
by the child care development block
grant I will also say that for the past
two years new Futures has convened a
broad group of stakeholders to identify
pressing issues facing childcare
providers teachers and families in order
to identify and craft important policy
Solutions one of the clear issues that
um has arisen is the fact that children
who are displaying more complex uh
social and emotional Behavior aval needs
are often struggling to find access to
child care and that is because um there
are limited resources for kids who do
not have a diagnosed disability it is
also very hard to diagnose a young child
with a disability so we are in this
space where there are lots of Children
at Risk but we don't have the necessary
supports within our system to ensure
they have access to child care and this
is shown number one not only through um
anecdotal stories but the but the fact
that our utilization of this child care
differential is really low what happens
is that there is either a suppression of
ratios in child care centers far below
license capacity this is to allow
teachers and providers to be able to
manage class rooms with high needs
children or children who are at risk of
developmental delay or disability cannot
find centers which are willing or
equipped to take care of them so to
address this issue s SP 596 proposes a
modification of the definition of
disability to allow for these
differential payments um to centers with
children who are screening high risk for
developmental um delay or
disability the differential payment is
only $100 a week but from our um
feedback from providers this really
would be a critical payment for them to
be able to um employ classroom based
approaches to ensure that those kiddos
are receiving services in classrooms
with um other peers and not just
receiving Services outside of the class
room I want to address the uh question
from the representative on what does it
mean to be at risk that really is a
clinical definition in early childhood
we do develop not me but providers do
developmental screening which show that
kids um on a raing scale either have a
developmental delay or disability or
they're at high risk and that is really
because there are many Early Childhood
interventions that can help prevent that
delay to um becoming a fullblown delay
or disability or ensure that that child
is on a path to um full and happy
development so when we think of things
like that that's like a speech
impediment or speech delay a fine motor
skill so it's at risk meaning that
without intervention that can worsen but
um at risk does not mean every single
child there would be a screening tool
that would identify those
children questions from the commit thank
you questions from the committee yes
represent Woodcock good morning thank
you for being here uh just a question un
sure you have the answer probably guess
you do I'm looking on line 20 on the uh
uh Bill and it talks about on the bill
you thank just caught you off got the
first question no that's fine I got it
thank you um line 20 and one on the
first page it talks about or other
approved licensed professional yeah do
you know what that means I don't so that
would be as I said a um certified
occupational speech therapist or other
type of Early Childhood trained
professional that is used to working
with young children to help them
overcome their um delays okay thank you
so much you're welcome thank you I I
have one question first here uh we
oftentimes deal with uh students
children that are ages three through
five very rarely do we ever go down
below that age that's really the domain
of HHS y
um you're you're talking here about
students in which age bracket this would
be um any child who is old enough to
enter um a child care center so that
could be a infant all the way through
age5 okay so I do have a followup on
that then uh I'm I always look at the
bottom the
appropriation and there was a line or
two put in dealing from the Senate that
if oura money is available if other
federal funds are available we we talk
about 375 ,000 there then they put in
the $1 um can you talk to that a little
bit yes so um during discussions with
the Senate there was some concerns
around March revenues but the Senators
identified this as an important priority
and wanted to carry the conversation
forward into the house so our
understanding is that um this would be a
discussion for finance to determine
whether or not there's flexibility in
existing funding or other sources to be
able to support this policy change thank
you better be prepared because I've seen
several other bills come in with the
same language Che uh going forward to
representative Damon and then represent
belch thank you Mr chair good morning
and thank you for being here um so I
have a background question and then
probably a followup could you just tell
us a little bit more about the basis of
the child care scholarship program just
a broad picture of it please sure so um
the childcare scholarship program is
supported primarily through our
childcare development block grant which
is a federal block grant which allows
the state to create a subsidy program to
help lowincome Working Families access
child care so based on income and
enrollment a child care center will
receive a certain amount of funds to
offset the cost of child care for
low-income families so the childcare um
scholarship program doesn't go to
families it goes to Providers and it
allows low-income families to be able to
access Child Care given if you've heard
probably many times the extreme costs of
child
care follow up thank you and thank you
so in your written testimony you note
that the Child Care Program currently
provides differential payments if the
children have a formal diagnosis of a
disability of $100 per week so that's in
addition
to the child care scholarship that any
uh low-income child might be eligible
for is that correct correct so that
would in fact in effect be if you had a
family receiving you know $150 towards
their um Child Care each week and that
child had a diagnosed disability that
Center would receive an extra $100 for
that child and it is in recognition that
children with high needs or disabilities
need different types of supports within
the child care
setting Bel no come back to than you Mr
thank you Mr Sher uh and thank you for
being here to take these questions um
I'd like to get a little bit deeper into
the issue of identifying uh students
with um with disabilities as as as far
as it says those who are risk for and
you mentioned that there are clinical
guidelines for that so I'm curious would
would a portion any portion of that
clinical guidelines include Aces or
adverse childhood event scoring I can't
speak exactly to that um the traditional
there are a number of authorized
National screening tools um their ages
and stages questionnaire is the number
one that we use but I can't say whether
or not there's a child specific Aces
screening tool I think that that um the
impact of Aces is often shown in the de
development of children so you would see
it that way but I can't speak to whether
or not there's a specific Asus screening
tool that would be valid so one thing I
want to emphasize is that um there are
federal guidelines about what we can
cannot do with childcare scholarship
funds so the amendment is written to not
identify specific screening tools
because the screening tools change and
they need to me meet certain state and
federal guidelines and also we want to
give DHHS the difference to ensure that
those were the best tools also in here
is a need to do verification so if
there's an ages and stages questionnaire
done at a child care center before a
child is enrolled and that indicates
there's a high risk of developmental
delay that would have to be verified by
a licensed professional so just to give
a little bit more context of what needs
to
happen if if I may just a yes thank you
um so one of the reasons I I wanted to
get deeper into this is is because these
services that are offered to various
students now they're certainly needed by
some students but they're not they do
have the potential to be harmful if
they're offered if they're given to
students who don't necessarily need them
um now at least we have if we have a
diagnosis we have some level of
certitude that that these services are
actually necessary but without a
diagnosis should we have concerns about
the risk of introducing these potential
treatments and other things to students
so I think um sorry to interrupt but I
think the clarification here is the
child care center is not offering a
treatment we're supporting the child
care center to have additional capacity
to keep those kids within their Center
so one thing we heard is a number of
children who have more complex
developmental chall Alles are being
kicked out of child care because
childcare Centers do not have the
Staffing or training or expertise to be
able to ensure those kids um can stay
there and that in part has to do with
the pressures on the child care centers
the long weight lists so to take in a
child that is more complex but could
benefit from being around their peers
Child Care Centers have to suppress the
number of other children that they can
have in the classroom and that's just
because the child demands more um from
the center itself so I want to clarify
that this bill does not create a
treatment for kiddos it allows that
Center to hire a pair professional to
come in to support the teacher it helps
them to um uh purchase classroom based
programs or initiatives that may help um
bolster the Child Care Center's ability
to take in a diverse um type of uh
children just a a followup to what you
were saying and then I'll go back to
represent Damon then represent uh or
beside me um the difference between
student and children I don't want to mix
and match these terminologies here we
have students in grades K through 12 but
we also deal with child F early in three
three through five ages below age three
we're not talking students are we so we
need to get that clarified Y and I will
say that um for that Age 3 to 5 child
find is a great resource but often those
Services may not be done in the
classroom with peers or the child is
offsite and so this is really about how
do you equip a child care center to be
in a better position to take all kids or
consider all kids because the reality
right now is that many centers based on
the pressures on our child care system
in New Hampshire are not taking these
children in and it is creating not only
a burden on the workforce but on
families when you cannot find a child
care center that you know your child
will be safe at and be supported at and
I do not um you know pass judgment on
Child Care Centers because it is a lack
of capacity it is a lack of funding and
although this is a small amount we have
heard from centers it would be extremely
helpful um in their ability to and
desire to serve all children in this
state thank you representative Damon and
then represent dry thank you Mr chair
and thank you again and then I'll come
down could you speak
to um the results of facilitating a
child's developmentally appr apprpriate
Care at a younger age in terms of their
capabilities going forward what is
likely to happen and I know that's a
broad question um I can provide more
specific details on the return on
investment um around early intervention
and um children being able to be um in
child care and going back to Aces we
know that one of the major interventions
in a positive way for children who have
experienced adversity and have a high
Asis score is high quality child care so
being in situations where there are
strong serve and return relationships
that help that brain architecture
results in lots of savings not only to
the state but also in that child's life
being able to build that strong
foundation so that they can be a um a
hardworking member of you know New
Hampshire's future so it's an important
investment PR and dry thank you and
thank you for taking my question in my
own Hometown we have a variety of Child
Care situations there are people that do
it in their home there is a a a business
that uses a building in town and now
there's talk of pre at the school are
all those varieties eligible for the
scholarship fund yeah that's one of the
most wonderful things about our child
care scholarship program is that it
allows child care to be in lots of
licensed settings so that can be a home
setting that can be a a faith-based
setting that can be a child care center
so at the core of it really is um
parental choice and that where do you
want your kid to be best be served based
on your values and systems and um
community so again this bill would also
provide that support to those centers as
long as they are accepting um of they
participate in our child care
scholarship program and the child in
question qualifies for child care
scholarship so again this is a program
that is aimed at lowincome working New
Hampshire families represent Miler and
then represent uh Pell thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here you
mentioned the uh issue again of lowi
income it's interesting this is kind of
a new new uh area for us we usually
dealing with kids either either prek or
not this young of a child so the
question I have you you mentioned low
income could you define low income and
also is there an annual recertification
of the families to be able to
participate in this program thank you
yes and that's a great question um
through bipartisan efforts last year
this legislature um modified what low
income was so right now the cap is 85%
of State median income at that point and
above you don't qualify for scholarship
any longer and um the amount of your
scholarship is based on steps um that
are determined by your family's income
and size so it's variable I can provide
you all with some background so you have
Clarity on exactly how much those income
brackets are I don't remember the off
the top of my head so it is based on um
family size and income with a cap and
there is annual recertification just
like any other program you're
welcome represent pet now thank you and
thank you for being here and taking my
question can you um give me an example
of some of the children who might be
turned away from these Child Care
settings yeah so um in my testimony and
I think Senator rardy it's children who
may um be presenting with um ADHD or
hyperactivity or Autism but they have
not yet been screened by child fine
because they're not three um and they
may not have had a formal diagnosis for
a number of reasons um it also can be uh
individuals who are new to this country
and they do not speak English yet and so
it is very difficult for them to
assimilate and we do not have the
training or capacity within the staff to
be able to provide those um supports it
also can be kids who experienced um
complex trauma so children that have
been in the foster care system that are
now um you know at the point of living
in a safe and stable environment and
they're being introduced into child care
and they have many Behavioral Health
needs that cannot be that aren't
diagnosed or addressed um in traditional
means thank you very much represent
cascaden thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um so do you have
any insight on why it sounds like there
is um a need obviously in the early
child in the child care setting for more
support or more assistance have you got
any insight on why that is
so that's a complicated question um you
all are very used to uh focusing on K
through 12 and the first thing I'll say
is our child care system doesn't have um
a a subsidy that is for every child
there are not requirements that young
children from you know birth through
age3 receive uh uh special services u
based on their diagnosis often that is
determined whether or not the family has
adequate access to health care and there
are other um social barriers whether it
is financial so these children um are
not in the same system as K to2 and
there are many gaps in funding and
support our child care system is
tuition-based so um there are many
market dynamics within our um child care
system that the expectations are similar
through K through 12 but the funding
streams are not which is why looking at
our child care development block grant
is so crucial how are we maximizing
those federal dollars to ensure that
we're really helping our low-income
working families and their
children further questions represent
whitcock thank you again for taking my
question um in the child care block
grant program now about how many
youngsters are being serviced
I do not want guess between five and
6,000 wow okay and I should also note
there are some um there are traditional
children and then there are children who
are protective and pro protective and
preventative um who access Child Care um
if they are in the um our child
protection
system than can just final question I'm
going back to follow up on what
representative lad asked a minute ago
about the funding piece I want to make
sure I understood correctly what this
says um when I'm looking at the end of
the bill 29 and and then on page uh 2
one two and three am I to interpret
particularly on page two the line one
that actual State
funds is going to be no ma no more than
$1 that is what was um so this is so
this is really not a state taxpayer fund
this is this is a redistribution of
federal money and how it goes I will
leave that question hopefully for
finance but there is some Nuance around
um figuring out how we fund this both
maximizing what we have for our
childcare scholarship and minimizing our
state fund appropriation okay thank you
so much you're welcome just a followup
uh regarding Medicaid we have Medicaid
to for the schools we work with
HHS does that Medicaid do offer any
support down on age three
to less so this is a um complicated area
and yes if a child has a diagnosed
disability Medicaid will pay for certain
interventions however those
interventions cannot be classroom based
so really when you're looking at helping
a child in that zero to three age you
have to have a matrix of different
funding streams and types of services I
think one of the the largest gaps is the
idea that how do we keep children in uh
rooms with other children because we
know how important that is this bill
provides a small um differential to
allow those classroom based approaches
whether it's supporting the teacher or
the child specifically um the ways in
which we can support young children 0 to
three through Medicaid are very very
limited and they are not conducive or um
they don't really support uh child care
as a whole and the child care provider
often can't be the one because those are
more interventions and treatments they
are not um classroom based support
and a follow-up question I noticed that
the effective date on this is January 1
2025 are you working on the annual year
the fiscal year and and uh there's also
rule making in here as well is that all
attached somehow yes so the um effective
date is there to give DHHS time to
engage into rule making so that um it
can be effectively rolled out at that
time and six months is enough time that
is what um DHHS and I discussed and
seems like would' be ample time for this
thank you are there further questions
from the committee yes representative
Damon thank you and thank you
again would it be correct to uh
recognize that helping the students who
would qualify under this proposal to be
in a normal child care setting is also
good for the other children there
yes further questions thank you very
much Rebecca you're welcome thank you
you're welcome uh I'd like to invite
Kathy
Holmes good morning there there you go
yes Kathy Holmes one thing I did remind
have been asked by the committee we have
some Ren renovation or not renovation
destruction going across the street here
and it gets noisy at times so when there
are people speaking can you speak really
closely to the mic so all can hear
especially that side of the room they're
having difficulty okay Kathy Holmes Chai
Chester um I just got this bill last
night this isn't the bill but this was
my testimony and listening I've been
altering it so you see I I'm
understanding more about the bill even
now um my career has been in teaching
for 40 years and
um I um my view is that the the
Democrats well no I won't start with
that I'll go with
um well the Democrats do have a Playbook
and this is what I saw in all my years
identify more learning disability
problems learning um difficulties and
you get more budget you get bigger they
want
more control and more
um more rule I'm sorry um but the
Playbook that I saw then is is in this
bill too it's at the root it's expanding
the money they
get and
um this bill is rushed there's another
tactic that they use I'm sorry that um
some Republican friends have joined in
on this on this bill but there's a red
flag too whenever a republican agrees
with a Democrat Sailors take
warning um yeah yes I hear you represent
luno I would appreciate that we're not
going to be critical either Democrats or
Republicans in here this has
co-sponsorship on that bill if we look
at it Prime sponsor yeah I got it I got
it so we're not going to do any more of
this one way or the other Mr chair point
of order can we point to Any House rule
would prohibit a member of the public
from speaking freely in this committee
representative I am speaking right now
to everybody here we're not going to
openly say that this is a Democrat bill
this is a Republican bill we're not
going there I said they join together or
or that it's a causation as a result of
one party or the other let's present the
bill I'm talking about myself too I'm a
republican understand I understand that
go ahead
please um another point is that it's
this sounds like welfare state um this
system that's been used in K through a
which was what I was had my career in is
now expanding down to infants so um I
think you need to steer clear of this
bill is there any further
information from the committee are there
any questions represent
Woodcock good morning um can you tell me
what grade level uh and what subject
kindergarten uh for most of the years
and then art and music up to 8th uh
junior high
history okay thank you further questions
from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much and I was in public and private
schools thank you are there any other
pink cards for this bill have not seen
any so we're going to close the hearing
on uh 596
one at 10 o' so we have about a 22
here
e
okay I'd like to have all committee
members take their seats we are ready to
move forward with uh the next bill which
341 this
from what's this7 side
why you walk over and get one on the
table
cards 25 26 there's more coming
okay good morning everybody we're ready
to go ahead with Senate Bill
341 uh this is a hearing relative to
mandatory Disclosure by School District
employees to parents and I'd like to
welcome Senator Lang thank you Mr
chairman thank you members of the
committee it's great to be back in front
of house education again um this is
probably one of your shorter bills one
page um it's a pretty simple statement
of um of it's a process bill um what the
bill does just like in many other areas
of law we have timelines and processes
that have to occur in order to keep uh
be accountable to our citizens um this
bill established a process and a
timeline it says that um Educators u
meaning school districts must respond to
a parent's written request for
information within 10 days and that
transparent there was followup
conversation talking about what if the
disclosure of the information puts the
child at risk so therefore in in section
two of this bill we establish an an
escape clause for the educator that says
that if an A Affair um and and good
faith determination of the credentialing
holder the educator that the disclosure
of the information would put a child at
risk they're not obligated to disclose
however educators are are mandatory
reporters if they know a child is at
risk they have an obligation to report
and this bill just says that if they
chosen not to disclose because it'll put
the child at risk that child is at risk
and therefore should have a man should
have a disclosure of that information
under the mandatory reporting um
component what happens if if someone
lies uh an educator lies doesn't
disclose what happens um the answer is
that that's a that's a matter of um
employment um and a matter of discipline
right in any one of our jobs if you were
to lie would you be expected not to have
disciplinary action the answer is no
right we would all expect that if we
lied um we would have displaying action
taken against us by our employer so this
bill does set a process that if it comes
out that there was a there was a lie was
was done it would be an investigation
determined when from fact whether there
was a lie and then that would be subject
to um the code of ethics U which I saw
that was handed out you guys all have in
front of you um the teacher code of
ethics and allow the local school board
or the Department of Education to take
action based on the code of ethics
that's the bill pretty straightforward
pretty clear um I I'm amazed that we're
having an argument that we that we even
anybody would oppose the idea that a
teacher should be truthful to a parent
um we're going to have a fight about
this we think that's okay not to be
truthful to a parent um I I I I struck
my three terms in the house serving
several times on this committee as a
substitute um and and over in the Senate
serving on the house education when we
talk about the trust relationship right
everyone talks about the trust
relationship that occurs and if you're
talking to the educator side of the
argument they believe that the priority
of the trust relationship is the teacher
to the student is the priority and if
you talk to a parent their argument is
that the trust relationship is between
the school school district and the
parent remember we have compulsory
education parents are obligated to send
their kid to
school they have to trust that that
school is going to act appropriately so
the trust relationship isn't between the
priority isn't between the teacher and
the and the student the priority
relationship is the trust that I give as
a father of four when I send my child to
a public school trusting they're going
to educate my child they're going to act
appropriately with my child and if I
have any questions about that I should
be able to ask the question put it in
writing and ask a question get a timely
honest response from the school I that's
my right as a parent for for engaging in
that trust relationship with public
education this bill just does that happy
to take questions thank you very much
Senator are there questions of Senator
Lang yes representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question based on the way that you
explained the what was your phrase
process that this is a process Bill and
what it is should it not therefore apply
to every educational setting that a
Hampshire again I think it it has to
deal with every credentialed um educator
right that's what it applies to every
credentialed
educator further questions represent
luno thank you very much much Mr chair
um thank you very much senator for
taking my question how is the uh
Department going to enforce this section
to determine whether there's been a
violation uh made by the credential
holder to supply both a complete and
honest response sure thank you for the
question first off I hope we don't have
an argument what honest means and what
complete means I'm pretty sure those are
pretty simple terms we all understand
what that means honest and complete it
would be like any other violation of the
ethics code when someone files a
complaint there's investigation done
they would make a determination on the
ruling whether or not the ethics code
was violated and then take action
accordingly thank further questions from
the committee not seeing thank you very
much oh the represent
whitcock thank you Senator take a
question I'm not going to go up on
honors to con complete um I do have a
question though um see to the mic yeah
thank you sir um thank you
so a parent
um for some reason whatever that reason
may be is going to submit a written
request to a teacher asking uh what is
the curriculum uh dealing with social
studies World War II and the teacher
responds that here it is or it's on the
website um but if a parent wants to know
more about something more
personal and they ask a teacher do you
you know for instance if my son John is
soup and Mary Sue has already conf John
has confined the teacher you know we're
involved we're in love y y
y the parent the teacher is required to
tell them that this youngster is yes
involved with that girl so again if it's
knowledge known to the teacher and and
it's not an it's not a guess it's not
hearsay it's not your instance that you
gave me there was a direct conversation
between the student and the and the
teacher yes I don't think in any
instance that a parent a school should
keep secrets from
parents follow up thank you
so I guess I'm not think of a secret I'm
thinking about
if if I come to a teacher as a student
and I understand your trust scenario
there I don't particularly agree with it
uh if I come to
the parent to the teacher as a student
and say you know I think Mary Lou and I
Mary Sue and I need help um is there any
place in you can you can suggest that we
go to get help um I don't want my
parents to know because we don't know
what's going on we just need to get more
help so they're not it's not a 51a it's
not child abuse it's not imminent danger
is I'm afraid my parents would not
accept this and they may throw me out
okay so those those don't meet any
criteria 51a but they do meet the
criteria of their student in need so am
am I precluding from saying well you
know what I think you should go to the
guidance counselor or to the maybe to
the school nurse or to the to the
doctor's office or depending what the
isue happens to be um and that I don't I
only could tell you that uh in in in
honestly if you're asking me but if a
teacher ask me in writing have you had
conversations with my youngster or do
you know anything about that I have to
respond to that and put that put that
youngster at risk well again so I I I I
would just like we have a difference
apparently in the trust relationship
argument where that trust relationship
resides um well I think it's with the
parents and you must think it's with the
students in this situation again schools
should not keep secrets from parents
period right is that when a when a
conversation occurs the teacher should
always play in in mind that when a
conversation occurs a relationship is
with the parent and have asked they have
to give an honest answer you can't lie
about that to
parent last one thank you last one
surely um so I want to go back to this
things just have you ever taught in a
school I'm sorry have you ever taught in
a school yes I have okay in a public
school yes okay good so you know that
the students would come to you ask you
things
um if that is the students's only
Lifeline to get information is through
that teacher and they're petrified that
you're going to tell the parent so we're
going to now allow the student to be out
there confused not have any accurate
Direction so because we're afraid we
have to tell the parent I mean can you
understand what my concern as a teacher
absolutely I understand your concern but
again I go back to the argument of trust
relationship the relationship is not
between the student and the teacher the
relationship is between the teacher and
the parent and the trust that the parent
puts in the public education system to
to uh to teach their child if you're
trust can I excuse me so if I so again
if that relationship is is is truthful
right and I and I I I would presume by
your question you think it's okay for
the teacher not to tell the parent that
information and hide it from the parent
I
disagree thank you very much are there
further represent Myer thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here so would
it be based upon what you've said so far
Senator would it be fair to say that
this bill would end the confidentiality
that teachers would have with students
is that correct I think I was pretty
clear teachers should never keep secrets
from parents so the answer is yes the
answer is Teachers should never keep
secrets from parents answer is yes I
don't how many times I can answer the
question well I I'm just asking you a
very simple question yes or teacher yes
teachers should not keep secrets from
parents so they there no confidentiality
then thank you represent B Bon thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I was just wondering I I
know that there was an initiative in the
department of education for a program
called one one trusted adult um how do
you see this bill interacting with the
program one trusted adult because the
whole premise of the program is to give
students who might be in need or need an
extra person to talk to at a certain
time might not be ready uh to talk to
their parents um to me this uh just
totally dissolves that program again
Nothing Stops the student from talking
to the parent I mean sorry student
talking to the teacher um Nothing Stops
that interact there's nothing in this
bill that says they can't have that
communication further questions I I want
to remind everybody we have 35 cards up
here and so if you have another followup
represent Bon can we do it quickly no
for yes representa Cornell I I think
there should be trust everywhere but
you're not getting to the trust between
the the student the child and the parent
so if the parent has to write a written
note to the teacher asking them about
something their child is doing wouldn't
the parent go to the child first and
shouldn't they have that relationship so
that they can trust the child to tell
them the truth thank you for the
question so I'm a parent to four kids
two boys and two girls I was lucky
enough to go girl boy girl boy um but as
I know with with my own children is that
a relationship between a parent and a
child es and flows there are times your
kids will tell you things you wish they
didn't tell you and there are time that
they tell they won't talk to you at all
that's the nature of a child and so if
I'm in the E side of that that
relationship with my child where the
child I I'm I know there's something
going on I child's not talking to me my
child so where do I go the next most
trusted adult which is a teacher and say
hey I'm concerned about my child I have
a question about my child you're the
next trusted adult Beyond me as a parent
that would have information will you
please help me with this right that's
what we're asking for us parents may
need help right because the relationship
between a child and a parent es and
flows right um and so in that case where
there's an ebbing of of the relationship
in a in with a a parent then the parent
has someone to go to as well the trusted
adult that they trust to teach their
child to educate their child to be with
their child for a significant portion of
their time the parent has the right to
go and say can you tell me can you help
me out here right and what where what
this bill says that they have an
obligation to
help further questions from the
committee represent beler
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
senator for providing us with this bill
I like I the intention in where this
bill is going I like very much I have a
little bit of a concern hoping you can
help assuage it a little bit so let me
paint you a picture of what I'm what I'm
thinking um so because this bill uses uh
the standard of good faith determination
of the credential holder and not the
reasonable person standard um and it
also goes on to talk about um well it
goes on to create a requirement for
reporting
um with the argument seemingly being
that if there is a requirement uh or if
there is a real reason to fear any sort
of imminent harm to a child due to
disclosing this information then there
really is also um a risk generally to
the
child um I guess my my concern comes in
is okay let's we we' played out the
scenario it's been reported because it's
in this bill even though the teacher
wouldn't have reported it otherwise
because weren't really thinking about it
now it turns out the complaint was
totally unfounded you go to the process
of of trying to hold somebody
accountable for is there a question yes
I'm just trying get to it real quickly
not a background yeah so okay so now the
standard to move forward is based on not
the reasonable person standard but the
good faith of this person is it even
possible realistically to think that
somebody could be held accountable for a
report that is false under that standard
in this so my answer is yes again so my
previous life I was a police prosecutor
so I understand the the the stages of of
um you know knowing Reckless negligent
those kind of things right so again in
this case if a teacher had a good faith
argument they have to make they have to
articulate that they have to be able to
you know if they're being challenge they
have to be able to say here's why I
thought that and then a reasonable
Arbiter would have to say no that well
you had a good reason to think that um
and so therefore you have the right to
withhold the information so I think
again it's about the investigation and
about why if a teacher chose to withhold
information what was their reasoning for
doing that and that is stand that
standard is based on good faith
reasoning representative
yeah thank it's been a long day already
I guess uh the uh the the concept here
of confidentiality has been re raised uh
during the uh questioning that you've
received and uh I'm I'm I'm wondering
are you are you aware of whether or not
there is any sort of standard
established in law with respect to
confidentiality between a student and a
teacher a teacher and a student is is
there any basis for this in law
confidentiality such that a teacher
would not have to disclose because of a
kind of a quasi confidential
relationship that's been established so
I I guess what you're trying to get to
is like a doctor patient relationship
attorney client privilege that kind of
thing is not to my knowledge at all
there's no such standard at all well
thank you I didn't think so thanks
further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much
Senator uh for the remaining people who
would like to testify here today we're
going to have a two-minute
um rule we'll put that in effect we have
we're broaching 40 cards here so I'd
like to first ask representative
selig is representative selig here
yeah par
me oh at the time yeah you you can do
yeah thank you Mr chair and members of
the education committee um although I'm
now a state representative as you
probably know from previous times I've
testified before you I used to be a
middle school and high school English
teacher I've been out of the classroom
for a while now some of my former
students have now turned 40 but they
still reach out to me for guidance and
advice in fact I was chatting with one
online just
yesterday um when I was a teacher I
worked really hard to Foster
relationships with all of my students so
that they would feel safe and
comfortable talking with me about
problems sometimes it was how to
navigate a difficult situation with
another teacher
sometimes it was because they'd had an
argument with their parents and needed
to find a safe space to vent so they
could go back and work out whatever the
issue was we would often practice how to
have that conversation so that they'd be
able to go back and no matter what their
parents say they'd be able to stay calm
to have the discussion with their
parents sometimes it was about
relationship issues sometimes it was
about relationship issues they knew
their parents wouldn't be comfortable
with in fact one of my specific
responsibilities as an adviser was to
create the kind of safe space for
students could come talk to me to get
the advice and guidance they needed on
how to navigate those challenging
aspects of their life and it was crucial
that I kept their confidence while they
figured out these issues there were some
occasions where kids might have come to
talk to me because they knew or maybe
they suspected they were lgbtq and they
just needed to figure out how to talk to
their parents about it when they felt
safe and ready to do so they might have
discussed their depression they might
have discussed their worries about their
parents' Health in one case I had a
student who came to me because it was
just after 911 and uh her father an
unnamed Pentagon official had just been
deployed that was certainly something I
had to keep extremely conf confidential
from
everyone
um so kids came to talk to me about all
sorts of things we need that safe space
we need to have that ability um in
general my feel my children do feel safe
I have two teenagers they feel safe
coming to talk to me about most things
but not everything
time's up okay I urge you to oppose this
bill because it's harmful to children
thank you very much are there questions
of the
represented not seeing any thank you
very much uh i' like to the rule we have
here we always have reps Senators speak
first but we have a lady here with five
children and I think be very appropriate
that we have you come forward and
testify if you want to do it at this
okay you didn't submit I didn't know if
you had a card in here or not and I
don't know who you are oh you're more
than welcome so then I'll go to
petrigno thank you Mr chair good morning
committee there we go there we go thank
you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh prior to becoming a state
representative I was a high school
teacher for 40 years both in private and
public schools and I'm here to speak on
behalf of my students who over the years
some have confided in me and didn't
necessarily want me sharing with uh
others there was the student who for
whatever reason felt the need to
complain to me about her mother almost
every day sometimes breaking down in
tears now as a young adult she and her
mother are best friends and I was happy
to pres preside over her wedding this
past summer there was the student who
confided the meting that she didn't
believe that her father loved her
because he took a strong interest in her
brother's Sports and attended all of his
games but didn't go to any of her school
events and didn't support her Ambitions
to go to college I remember the student
who shared with me how sad she was
because she broke up with her boyfriend
she did so because she believed it was
inevitable anyway since they'd soon be
going off to college and I told her you
know you should just enjoy senior year
and see how things play out well today
they're married my only regret is they
didn't named their firstborn child after
me most disheartening was the student
who told me about her mother's mental
illness and that her father was an
alcoholic and that when he'd come home
from work drunk they would argue and she
would go out to the car to escape
sometimes falling asleep there today
she's married she has her own child and
I can go on and on and on with stories
kids come to talk to their teachers
about all kinds of things my point is
this these are real people these are
kids who sometimes feel the need to talk
with a trusted adult especially if for
whatever reason they just don't feel
comfortable or are not ready to talk
with their parents just to vent to share
their worries and concerns bounce ideas
off of to be reassured validated and to
know that they can be open talk freely
without being harshly
judged last Point quickly please I serve
on children and family law okay and I
can tell you that there are many many
dysfunctional families out there in a
perfect world parents could talk to kids
and kids could talk to parents but we
know that's not a reality plain and
simple this is a harmful legislation and
I urge you please to uh vote in
expedient to legisl thank representative
are there questions yes representative P
or no thank you Mr chair and thank you
for um taking my question you gave a lot
of examples of instances where students
came to you and confided in you but have
you ever had an exam do you have any
examples of parents asking you question
questions that you felt like they
shouldn't have the answer to no that's
that's the thing that I find quite
interesting about this bill is that
after 40 years I really never had any
student ask me questions or come to me
to confide in U matters of their sexual
orientation or identity it's just a
matter of kids opening up and talking
but I mean should that parent ask
me um is my child talking to you to you
about my relationship with my husband do
I have to reveal yes she told me that
you struggle with mental illness and
your husband comes home drunk every
night I mean that would be incredibly
awkward and inappropriate but that
student really felt they needed to go to
an adult and just get that off their
chest and just you know just express it
and should a parent ask me what is it
that um my kid is talking to you about
and I have to answer those kinds of
questions kids need to talk to an adult
sometimes just a vent so I don't know
thank you first the questions represent
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here I just wanted to to nail down
one part and and uh be clear uh you were
talking about students when you would
you you would been involved confiding
things like sexual orientation and
whatnot is it is it your intent to
testify this committee that children in
public schools should be able to talk
about sex with employees of the public
employees of public schools uh privately
and with expectation of confidentiality
from their parents I think that teachers
most teachers are responsible adults and
they're surrogate parents and that when
students come to them and ask them
honest uh questions uh they expect
um I have to say that I loved being a
teacher and I loved my students and I
treated them like I would treat my own
my own kids my own my own children uh I
I took my profession very very seriously
uh this past weekend I was at a
political event in man
and a 50-year-old man saw me and said
excuse me are you Mr patrino and I said
yes he said I had you in school many
years ago and wow I just can't believe
that I've run into you and I have to
thank you for all you did for me many
many years ago and I was surprised you
recognize me CU back then I had hair but
I I really felt good to know that I made
an impact on this person's life teachers
are surrogate parents and and good
teachers want to do good things for kids
and I really believe that this
legislation takes away that important
relationship when kids have no place to
turn to they can go to a teacher that
they trust and you can have honest and
open discussions with them and there's
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong at
all it's very healthy and normal and
natural thank you any further questions
from the committee thank you very much
representative thank you I'd like to
thank you very much as uh probably most
of you probably remember um I'm
represent Tim Horgan from stford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
and I actually never have been a teacher
but I was a uh but my uh although my uh
father's an educator he's a professor
and uh my actually my mother trained to
be a teacher too and I was a student for
many years so I know so I know I think I
know a thing or two about this issue
um and uh this bill you know comes at
the height of what I only describe as
Nationwide
anti-lgbtq Panic anti especially
anti-gay and anti-trans panic because
the b stands for bisexual and
everybody's at least somewhat bisexual
nobody's complete no straight person is
completely straight no gay person you
know is completely you know 100% 100%
gays so even they have so even uh people
so these issues are difficult for for
any Young person and this actually isn't
just about um you know issues about sex
or uh or gayness or straightness because
it it covers just about anything so it
would make it essentially impossible for
a child to discuss anything
confidentially with their teachers or
really any other adults at the
school um any parent will be able in
fact any parent made band report on just
about anything going on at the child
school that report has to come out
within a pretty short time period 10
business days which I um it's equivalent
to two weeks and the report has to be
made by the individual educator rather
by the school even that teacher isn't
really necessarily in a position to be
able to definitively speak for the
school or even you know give a useful
answer to the question so there's many
um there's many reasons why a young
person might discuss something with a
trusted adult which are not ready to
discuss with their parents I mean even
those of us um my parents both passed
away but even uh you know even when I an
even when I was an older person I
sometimes found things hard to discuss
with my parents that I could discuss
more easily with with other people and
if this becomes law confiden is only
allow this child is at imminent risk of
physical harm so the risk is your time
is up anyway it's a bad idea there's uh
just many problems it makes no provision
for um situation where the parent ask
for material information which violates
the privacy of someone else's child um
you have the written testimony I've
actually email to everyone subm your
pronounce and put it on the web portal
so you have three copies of it and so
this can't be fixed it's not needed so I
recommend that you uh find the nhpd to
legislate I'm glad to see thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee not see thank you yes it's
mccardy have to squeeze my three minute
speech into a two-minute speech so I
might have to talk a a little
fast
so uh I'm here to oppose SP 341 you know
every time one of these builds I'm sorry
just give your name first please oh Kate
mccardy I'm sorry I thought you you're
welcome okay uh so every time one of
these builds comes up my mind does this
thing it starts casting about trying to
think of some magical word or phrase
that will end this but I'm always
disappointed because there are no
magical words I can say that will fix it
but countless medical professionals
social workers and teachers have said
them over and over again these are
harmful and they keep repeating that I'm
a 911 dispatcher more times than I can
count a caller will say I don't know
what to do and I'll be saying all you
need to do is listen and I'll tell you
exactly what to do I see the same thing
happening here half of you are saying
trans kids what should we do and the
professionals are all saying all you
need to do is listen we're telling you
exactly what to do and that should be
enough when a bill comes before you do
you do research do you study all the
pros and cons do you do what we're
trusting you to do and Trust the
professionals the ones who know more
about these things than anyone else or
do you look for someone who gets their
stories from a subreddit who provides
only anecdotal evidence that can't be
fact checked when did one pathological
liar with a sandwich board become more
of an authority on transgender issues
than all of the professionals and the
actual trans people who are the subject
of these bills put together if you were
questioned down the line about why you
voted the way you did on these issues
how will you answer will you be able to
say I thought it was a bad idea because
all of the professionals said it was or
will you have to say I thought it was a
good idea because the lady with the big
sign said it was and well that's how our
party votes New Hampshire is at a
Crossroads make no mistake there will be
an accounting later on when the body
count Rises when the homeless teen
population grows when Gen Z AG is out
and demands answers because they will
this generation understands that people
don't need to dress a certain way in
order to be respected they understand
that simply addressing someone by the
pronouns they choose Will Do no harm
this generation has had enough they've
had enough of hiding during lockdown
drills and having to urinate in the
litter box because they can't come out
till it's safe and then reading the
today that the litter boxes are to
accommodate kids who identify
differently because as always someone
has to lie to try and turn the country
against trans kids your time is up oh
all right so just please please vote the
way you should are there questions from
the
committee thank you thank you uh Heidi
Heath
[Music]
honorable members of the committee good
morning thank you for hearing my
testimony today I'm Heidi kington Heath
and I serve as the executive director of
SE Coast outright we are New Hampshire's
oldest lgbtq plus organization and the
we are focused on serving youth across
New Hampshire I'm here today in
opposition to
s341 our objections are simple and clear
students deserve to be safe at school
they deserve the opportunity to have
safe and confidential conversations with
trusted adults in preparation for having
those conversations with their parents
and their caregivers they deserve the
opportunity to develop healthy autonomy
and to advocate for their own
well-being this bill puts the health and
well-being of lgbtq plus students an
already vulnerable group particularly at
risk the language in this bill is vague
and Broad it could be construed as a
mandate out students to their parents
before they are ready or in situations
where it may be unsafe to do so we know
that students learn best and are most
successful in a school environment when
they feel safe seen and protected the
department of education's own words
State clearly what we know to be true
research shows that youth who can name a
trusted adult outside of their home are
less likely to bully or be bullied
suffer from depression abuse substances
be suspended expelled or drop out of
school in short we are asking the state
to live up to what our own doe has
already advocated for and to protect
their relationship between students and
teachers including lgbtq plus students
at se Coast outright we work to Foster
Community empathy and understanding and
we believe this bill is detrimental to
that work thank you again for hearing my
testimony this morning thank you very
much other questions yes represent
McDonald thank you for your M um thank
you for your testimony and you mentioned
that part of this bill is vague and
would be detrimental and I'm just
curious what portion of the bill is
there a particular line that you find
problematic um we believe that the
language about completely and honestly
is not adequately defined in the bill
and could be misconstrued to be harmful
to students and may I follow up yes how
could that be misconstrued do you have a
way that you are interpreting that you
believe is different than what the
sponsor intended we I think I captured
that in my testimony but particularly
for the the youth that we serve we have
concerns that this could put students in
a position where they are outed to their
parents before they're ready to do so
because a teacher believes that they
need to operate within the confines of
how this bill is written thank you
further questions from the committee not
see thank you thank you very much thank
you pronounced my last name correctly
yay thank you okay I'm going to
abbreviate this for the sake of time
I've already submitted
online so my name is Pamela sinot and I
live in conquer and I'm a licensed
independent clinical social worker with
over 26 years of experience in the field
working with Children and adolescents
and their
families I have worked with several
teens who are members of the lgbtq plus
Community um I'm going to skip some of
this and go straight to the two things
that concern me about the bill one um
this has to do with the
language how will
the credential holder in all likelihood
either a teacher or a guidance counselor
be able to determine whether or not to
disclose
um quote would put the student at
imminent risk of physical harm abuse or
neglect and quote and be able to make
such a determination in less than 48
hours in order to quote file a report
within 48 Hours of such a
determination such a requirement would
further burden School staff and in
essence force them to take on another
role that of the quote outing plan
Le two the one type of risk to the
student that is not defined in SB 341 is
what is perhaps the most common risk
emotional abuse which can take many
forms which can take sorry can take many
forms the word abuse is included in the
bill but is not defined clearly
emotional abuse can include passive
aggressive behaviors like stonewalling
that is ignoring or not speaking to
someone or excluding a child from a
family
activity there are many ways to express
disapproval or
anger I urge you to vote in opposition
to this harmful and unnecessary Bill
thank you thank you Pamela are there
questions from the committee yes
represent
Woodcock good morning thank you for
coming in speaker uh in your
um experience as a social worker for
they said 26 years did you ever have
students referred to you that came to
you could they talk to their teacher and
said they should go see
you um oh usually from guidance
counselors okay thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much like to call call
thank you uh my name is Cameron muns I
was an art teacher uh in the state of
New Hampshire for 11 years and I'm a
proud trans person so I speak to you
today with professional and lived
experiences it is not likely that I will
change anyone's mind since this is a
performance day for all of us uh we the
public parade in front of you telling
you why we are right you cast a vote
regardless of how well we support hate
and ignorance or plead for com Common
Sense our rights and our decency what I
will ask is that you consider some
questions relevance how many cases are
you aware of that this is in response
to students will choose continue to
choose safe adults and decide not to
come out to others for critical reasons
regardless of this bill this bill only
stands to create undue fear and shed
light on the P pervasiveness of
misguided ignorance and hate knowledge
how have you prepared to vote on this
bill how have you educated yourself on
the topic what data backed information
are you basing this on debate and
conversation who have you heard from are
they parents or Guardians are they
educators are they students who have you
invited to the table it is not enough to
invite just opinion I urge you to
discover the why and The Who Behind that
opinion self-care what are you doing
after this
do you feel the need to stand in
community have you ever felt that need
following a vote what would you like to
put uh have any of you put yourself in
those shoes as someone with 11 years of
experience in the classroom and as a
proud
transperson these shoes have had to
stand for my uh community's rights and
dignity far too many times if you have
not been in these shoes you have no
business supporting this bill and if you
think about what representative said
about lies and being correct I need all
of you to consider if you have said that
you have
put time into actually uh looking into
the data of this and actually educating
yourselves on this I hope that you would
also hold yourself to the same standards
thank you thank you very much other
questions from the committee thank
Ser good morning thank you Nancy Brennan
she her I live in weer um I have several
problems with this bill first and
foremost it seems to be one in a number
of bills dealing with parental rights we
had earlier bills where teachers were
supposed to call
if they learn something and now this one
is if you are asked and I as a teacher I
taught for many many years middle and
high
school if I feel like there is some
desire out there to um vilify especially
Public School teachers and so this kind
of a bill allows parents who are sure
that teachers are doing this that and
the other thing I mean I had a kid uh
who uh came to me one day and into my
office broke down crying because his
parents were getting divorced he loved
his parents he didn't know they were
having troubles but then he heard that
his father had had an affair and so
telling me all this stuff and I'm
thinking okay I mean I was listening and
I was kind and he said and you can't
tell anybody cuz if I tell my friends
they'll tell their parents and if if you
tell my mother she'll be so mad cuz she
said don't tell anybody so I did what
most of us who have been in these kind
of situations did I sat with him and I
talked to him and I listen to him and I
convinced him to go to the guidance
counselor but also to find a way to
Broach it with his mother now if in the
meantime his father had sent me a letter
and said I know you are tutoring qu
Chris two days a week in algebra what
else do you talk about
would I have to relate that story I
think I'd be fired first and I think a
lot of us who have dealt with delicate
kids feel the same way one of my other
problems with this and I have a million
stories just like the Reps we Tau but
one of the other your time is
upk are there any questions from the
committee thank you very
much Beth
sour scare scare yes scare as
C I think it's SC that's me yep okay
thank you um thanks for taking my
testimony my name is Beth scare and I'm
a grandmother from nashwa and I support
this bill in 2017 Bruce L taught a
social studies teacher at Nasa High an
adviser to the school's gay straight
Alliance Club was arrested for sending
nude pictures of himself to several male
students and engaging in sexually
explicit conversations with them and
soliciting the students to send him
naked phot photos of himself of
themselves he also solicited them to
meet with him to engage in sex on the
app grinder in 2021 Timberland High
School teacher David Russell was charged
with two felony counts of sexual assault
for inappropriately touching a
16-year-old student he had formerly
taught in Nashua where he was accused of
touching young female students and
giving them therapeutic massages
teachers sexually abusing students is
not uncommon these teachers are too I
know the details of because of their
association with my city of
nashwa Google teachers sexually abusing
students in New Hampshire to find many
many more such cases many of those
testifying saying they are concerned
about protecting lgbtq students and that
we should automatically trust teachers
to do the best for their students and
these teachers can be trusted to keep
secrets from parents the truth is is
that no one cares about kids more than
their parents teachers are human and
fallible and have much less invested in
the well-being of students and have
their own interests at
heart many say The Spill undermines
trust between students and teachers but
those some same people think nothing of
undermining trust between those students
and their parents by allowing teachers
to hide
information children hide a lot of
critical information from parents when
they're taking drugs cutting themselves
starving themselves binging purging
driving recklessly and the list goes
on by the same logic I've heard from
many the fact that the child is hiding
that from parents means that the parents
can't be trusted with that information
that is
ludicrous the bill says that the teacher
does not have to tell parents anything
until the parent inquires If the parents
your your time is up okay anyway I think
teacher should not be lying about these
critical
issues and and because of this families
are fleeing Public Schools if you if
people care about public schools they
need to win back the trust of parents
please vote octop pass thank you are the
are the questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
much and I also have testimony from my
husband Steven scar um do you have
written uh testimony right there could
you hand that around so we could put it
in as anybody with written testimony
docket of the record okay I'd like to
good morning Nancy Beerman I would like
to State first of all that teachers are
not the kids friends and I'd also say
they're not surrogate parents either and
that has been stated a number of times
today when a child enters a school that
parent has known their child for many
many years a teacher will know a student
for
maybe 180
days 900 25 hours at that child's in the
elementary school by the end of the year
you don't know the history you don't
know the child you don't know the family
you don't know anything about that child
in the
circumstances How can any teacher
believe that they know what is best for
any student under that time limit I have
heard many people vilify parents and say
parents are wrong parents rights do not
end end when a child enters the school
building
and from being a teacher of 15 years and
I've taught uh students K to 12 they
come to school they complain about their
parents'
decisions be from what they wear to what
they eat to who they play with a parent
has the right to direct their child in
these decisions that is not the
teacher's job it's not
their right to do anything and say what
is right and wrong if a teacher is
concerned about a home situation they
should be reporting the concern to the
appropriate people I've also heard
teachers saying that they're coaching
and counseling these students again that
is not part of your teaching certificate
you are crossing a
line the idea that all parents are
guilty and presume guilty is wrong and
any teacher who thinks that lying to a
parent is right they are wrong I have
never ever lied to a parent in all my
years of teaching if a parent comes to
me and asks about a child or a situation
I have always told them the truth and
the fact that we have to sit there and
mandate teachers to tell the truth is
just wrong thank you thank you very much
pass the spill are there any questions
from the
thank you so much for taking the time to
hear my testimony uh for the record my
name is Courtney Reid I serve as policy
Advocate uh at the ACLU of New Hampshire
and we oppose this bill because it would
uh create an unlimited burden on
Educators with the complete and honest
standard uh and although this bill was
amended in the Senate it is still
insufficient to protect students from
harm um
in reading this bill uh we see that it
is uh unsafe unwelcome and
unworkable and we've heard numerous
times from various stakeholders in the
state such as service providers the
impartial Office of the office of the
child advocate families previous
teachers that this legislation would put
Children at Risk specifically less than
a month ago the office of the child
advocate had said that this bill would
threaten the health safety and intrinsic
right of Granite State lgbtq residents
and their families and that's because
this bill isn't about uh honesty when it
comes to asking questions from parents
it's about putting teachers in an
impossible and unreachable situation
where they're being required to meddle
in what should be private family Affairs
and this complete and honest standard is
something that we heard in previous
testimony is really used in law for
discreet requests like a list of assets
uh or things like that not um complete
and honest in regard to what information
a student might have told a teacher in
confidence or what a teacher might have
heard uh a student say walking through
the halls and I wanted to um pose a
scenario where perhaps uh in compliance
with this
bill uh a parent puts a request asking
uh you know several questions like uh
what does my child have uh for lunch you
know who do they eat lunch with what
clubs are they in um and what sexual
orientation is my child how is a teacher
supposed to to answer that with this
Omission requirement are they supposed
to your time is up leave one push and
blank I just wanted to express that even
a
non-answer uh implies something that
could be harmful for this for the child
in this situation and we've heard so
many advocates Express that uh this
isn't enough to protect children and I I
go at length you very your time is up
thank you question yes representer
Cornell Thank you thank you for your
testimony um do you think a result of
this I know there's the program we have
in New Hampshire you know one trusted
adult but if this actually goes into
effect and certified teachers not
non-certified teachers who are also in
the building but just the certified
teachers who will have an Ethics
complaint filed against them if a
student came to a teacher
I'm having a really big problem and I
really need to talk to somebody said
well don't talk to me and that and the
student will no longer have any trusted
adults to talk to do you think that
might
happen I think that this Bill thank you
for your question I think that this bill
puts Educators in an impossible
situation and one of the things we
actually saw in the teacher shortage
report that was released just this fall
is that bills like this um have prompted
stress and concerns of consequences and
is one of the reasons that educators are
actually leaving the state and so part
of the one trusted adult program is that
that information is meant to stay
between the child and the educator
unless um there are instances of self
harm threats to harm others you know
typical instances that we would want to
uh get child protective services or
other investigations involved in but
this I think and we've heard from the
sponsor of the bill would completely
deprive that confidentiality and take
away that opportunity for students to um
build up the confidence and trust with
with people before talking to their
parents um and I think another point of
concern with that is that um that that
standard is unworkable so imagine uh a
parent hears an answer that they don't
like who's to say whether or not that
answer is complete or true and if there
is a disciplinary action or the
investigation that's listed in the bill
there's no explicit provision in the
bill that gives an educator an appeal
process so I think we're hearing from
teachers that there's a real concern
that their careers might be on the line
when they're just trying to to do their
jobs um and as far as I know there's
also been no call for this bill uh from
Educators thank you so much thank you
leus I'm thinking about um seems that
people are assuming that that teacher is
the only one who knows anything about
that kid and my question is if somebody
else who also knows whether by
observation or being a friend or
whatever should happen to say something
and the parents should happen to find
out say a friend says something to their
parents and the parents say something to
the kids's
parents and the te and the parents have
asked the teacher the teacher hasn't
either lied or not given a proper or or
refused to answer the question is if
those parents then do something harmful
which is what we're talking about right
if a parent does something harmful
because they find out are they not just
as likely to do something harmful if
they find out from somebody else rather
than the teacher and should not the
parent if they think if they truly
believe that something harmful should be
done reported because otherwise it may
still be done because that parent may
find out in a different
way thank you for your question
representative so to follow um and
trying to understand are you suggesting
that it would be better for parents to
find out from a teacher that might have
heard something in the hallway as
opposed to from another Community member
no what I'm saying well it could be
because a teacher is a mandatory
reporter what I'm saying is if the
teacher is legitimately afraid that
something will happen if the parents
find out should they not be
reporting and will lying make that any
different thank you for your question
and so my understanding is that if a
educator um who's Bound by this bill has
a good faith determination of uh
imminent risk of physical harm abuse or
neglect they then put in a Report with
ghhs and omit that
information what we have heard from
Advocates is that this is insufficient
to protect youth because the uh dcyf
only gets involved when there are
suspected incidences of abuse
not risks of abuse happening they only
get involved after there have been
reports of that abuse happening and so
um what I was speaking to also was when
there is a non-answer i I think we're
Advocates are also afraid of what might
happen um in a in a non-answer scenario
what does that imply to a parent who
educators are not you know trained to
handle these intimate Affairs what is
that what what will the response be from
a parent um Educators really have no
place in getting involved in what are
very sensitive intimate family
situations and uh I think this bill as
we've heard from many other peoples puts
them in a situation where they might
unintentionally put a child at risk and
that there aren't enough safeguards to
prevent that from happening thank you no
we're not going to go that uh
representative uh
dry thank you and thank you for taking
my question I'd like to ask a little bit
about the one trusted adult program do
you know much about that uh thank you I
can try to answer your question but I
might defer to some folks who are more
active in the education space okay so
I'm just reading that that two years ago
it started to to uh
get into the districts for training and
I just wondered on um what the progress
of that was and also if it does kind of
establish confidentiality for that
information in the training that that
they do for
this thank you for your question I think
I would defer that to some other folks
from teachers associations to better
answer thank you represent
ter thank you um early on in your
testimony you used the word in
sufficient perhaps you may
recall and um I I remember that you
characterized the amendment to the bill
in the Senate and then as passed in the
Senate as being
insufficient uh the change being
insufficient representing the American
civil liberties Union I'm sure you can
appreciate how important Precision is
with respect to the language and the
terms that you use so I I'm curious to
know um what in your view the view of
the American civil liberties Union would
constitute sufficient
changes uh I think that that would be a
conversation that I would love to have
with you and uh in addition with some
lawyers at the ACLU I just wanted to
Echo again that after that amendment was
introduced we had still seen opposition
um from a policy perspective from
various stakeholders in New Hampshire
which includes the office of the child
advocate so just to be clear you're
you're not prepared to offer any Sugg
suggestions as to what would move in the
direction of sufficient not at this time
thank you
Woodcock
thank you okay I'm I'm from face um just
I back on a question that you I want to
make sure I heard it correctly the New
Hampshire State Department of office of
child advocate opposes this Bill yes
thank you thank you further questions
from the committee
thank you very
Hansen good morning everyone my name is
Peter Hansen I'm a resident of Penbrook
Hampshire I'm also the father of five uh
my wife and I have five kids
um so I would hope I have some vested
interest in this conversation and
especially in this bill I'm I'm
commenting in support of SB
341 um let's be honest here the trust
between the schools and parents has
already been broken or we wouldn't be
having this conversation right now it's
unfortunate but people don't always do
the right
thing and that's why we actually have to
sit in the room like this today and have
a discussion about whether a school
official will have to tell the truth
truth to a parent who's put in writing a
question about their child their minor
child not a grown-up I know some of the
previous speakers have talked about
grown-ups coming back to them and
everything else we're talking about
underage minor children who haven't
fully developed their
brains who have all kinds of
ideas who are to be educated by the
education
system the parents have the right to
know what is being talked
about by school Educators with their
children I'm not condemning all teachers
in this I have great relationships with
the school that we're in there's many
great teachers but we can't be naive
enough to think that all teachers will
do the right thing and make good
decisions and not promote their own
agendas or beliefs onto our
children and as we all learned in school
most laws and regulations get created
because people don't always do the right
thing
case in point there's been articles in
the Chicago Sun Times New York Times
documenting cases where parents ried to
about their children and their
transitioning one of those parents was
actively engaged with the administration
of the school regarding their child's
well-being as she sense something was
wrong and the school still
withheld the information that they were
calling that young child by a different
name a different
gender under her nose for over six
school in short she had to rescue her
system there was another case in
California for two years the school had
been calling their child by a different
name when was she supposed to find this
out at graduation at the graduation
ceremony when when the name was called
out come get your
diploma is that appropriate
is that what you are all advocating for
those of you that are opposed to this
bill that you would hide this so the
out I'm in favor of this bill because
school officials should not have to tell
the should have to tell the truth of ask
they should not be in the business of
picking and choosing to tell what
they're going to tell the truth about
they don't get to decide that your your
time is up thank you I appreciate your
time I would hope that all of you would
vote to support this Bill thank you
other questions from the committee not
see thank thank you very
brigata hi my name is Laura Bata um I
live in Hudson New Hampshire um parents
need the whole truth about their child
teachers have if teachers have a true
concern there's the child protective
services angle but the idea that
teachers are supposed to substitute
their judgment for parents' judgment
parents are the ones raising their
children parents are
invested and a lot of the talk remind
really sounds like people don't trust
parents and people expect parents to
somehow be fragile children may have
fears that oh my mom and dad they're
going to be so upset and even if parents
are upset or disappointed that doesn't
mean that parents can't take it there is
such a fragility that is being described
here um that I I really questioned so
again please support the bill and
parents are the ones raising the
children thank you thank you very much
are there any questions not see thank
you very
okay this yeah sometimes I have to hear
the
for good morning and thank you for
hearing my testimony for the record my
name is Emma Sven I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures solves Pol uh
solves problems through policy change
and is supportive of a robust and strong
system of care for children new Futures
is here in opposition of Senate Bill 341
because it discourages students from
establishing support networks outside of
their families which has been shown to
improve mental health outcomes for
students who experience mental health
challenges
um as you'll see in my testimony the
rates of depression suicidality anxiety
and other concerning mental health
conditions are are very high for lgbtq
Youth and this is a direct response to
feelings of um discrimination against
them when they when lgbtq young people
feel supported in their communities
schools and with their parents they have
mental health outcomes on par with their
peers it is clear that when lgbtq kids
are outed to their parents prior to
their um feeling ready to they have
higher levels of depressive symptoms and
lower amounts of family support than
those who wait and come out at their own
time and when they are fully
comfortable um for those reasons new
Futures opposes this spill and would ask
the committee to vote uh itl I'm happy
to take any questions thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee not seeing you thank you very
yeah so I didn't turn the last one off
started good morning good morning Mr
chairman my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of we and I oppose this
bill for two reasons first children
should be able to live honestly and have
a say in matters about their own lives
Senator Lang's of the world is that a 16
or 17year old is
legally an infant they have no more
rights than a kindergartener in his view
the trust relationship is solely between
the school and the parents there is zero
room for children in Senator Lang's view
of the world that does not make sense if
you've raised teenagers you know that
they grow up and start to have a say in
their own life also New Hampshire law
supports that notion when it's divorce
cases the Supreme Court of this state
has held that by the time they're 13 or
14 children's interests and statements
about what they want take precedent in
special education law by the time
children are in the eighth G grade
they're encouraged to participate in
their IEPs Senator Lang says though that
until year 17 in 364 days you have no
rights as a child the second problem
with this bill is that it will break up
amilies this bill is not all about
mandatory reporters it creates a brand
new category of mandatory reporters in
169c you're a mandatory reporter if the
abuse or neglect has already happened if
there's evidence of it this bill says if
a teacher thinks there may be imminent
risk of harm they have to report so take
an example child says I don't think my
dad can handle knowing that I'm LGBT Q
he'll throw me out of the house so the
teacher says I don't really think I
should tell the dad there's nobody's
been thrown out of the house already
it's a risk that the child might be
thrown out of the house but under this
bill mandatory reporting that has to be
filed with the the government that leads
to a mandatory investigation all kinds
of procedures that would be is that my
time you have a very good ears Mr
Trumble thank you Mr where no that was
the end of your time okay any questions
for
David thank you very much you're welcome
jackow hello members of the committee my
name is Lind Jak house I am in
opposition to SP
341 the individuals in support of this
bill are portraying this bill as a do
not lie to parents bill
if this were simply a bill that stated
that the many lgbtq people you see here
in opposition today would not be an
opposition to this bill this bill
doesn't explicitly name situations
related to lgbtq youth like last year's
sb272 but we know that the effect of
forced outing will be the same this is
not just if a student confides in a
school employee this is expecting all
Educators to report anything that they
may have overheard regarding students
how do students feel safe at school when
they feel like the people around them
could report anything they say most
likely teachers will have to record many
details of sensitive conversations and
in the event that they are asked by a
parent and when students see them doing
that they will be less likely to have
necessary conversations with trusted
adults this bill will have a chilling
effect Additionally the language around
reporting cases of abuse and neglect is
unworkable this bill requires Educators
to submit a report to DHHS if they
believe abuse or neglect could take
place however DHHS does not respond to
reports of potential abuse or neglect
these children will be failed if there
is not extremely strong evidence of
abuse or neglect parents and teachers
should be partners this bill assumes
that they are adversaries and puts pits
them against each other teachers should
be able to say that's really a
conversation you should have with their
child if parents are asking if their
child is
lgbtq many lgbtq young people feel a
strong need to come out to peers first
for regardless of whether or not their
parents are affirming when I realized
that I liked girls when I was in high
school I knew it wasn't safe to come out
to my dad and I planned to come out to
him only after I was no longer
financially reliant on him when my
father did find out I had feelings for
my best friend by hacking into my
personal internet accounts he told me
that I was disgusting and immoral and
that's not how I was raised took away my
phone and there was a moment when I
thought I might be sent to conversion
therapy which was leg very time is up
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions from the committee welcome uh
questions from the
committee thank you oh you represent
Damon I didn't see your hand up thank
you Mr chair thank you taking my
question could you please tell us how
things turned out with your father he
never ended up accepting me I ended up
going to a college that did not even
allow an lgbtq student group to exist on
campus and that was the first thing that
I tried to change as a student um I
grateful for learning how to organize in
a tough environment
um but um unfortunately I'm I'm thankful
to have a firming family and my mom and
my brother thank you for being here and
for your thank you thank you further
questions from the committee thank you
very much uh Michelle
silly
FY
yes it no the last is
good morning good morning good morning
good morning chair lad and honorary
members of the committee my name is
Michelle silly foisey I live in Temple
and I'm here in opposition to S SP
341 I am a mother of
six sorry having given birth to four of
my children being blessed with the other
two through marriage I've always been a
strong Advocate from my children from
the moment they entered my world I have
never felt they belong to me they are
not my possessions I've always called
them my little people as they are just
that their own person I believe they
have the same rights as we as adults
have and as parents we are here to see
that they are allowed these rights I did
not become a parent to control their
path and future I was not aware that my
now 17-year-old had been experiencing
gender dysphoria since the age of 13
feeling lost in their own body they
struggled to even look at themselves in
the mirror but yet I didn't not hear of
this until their 16th year last summer
my team was in such a dark place that
they tried to take their own life while
feeling incredibly isolated and alone in
their thoughts today they have the full
support of their parents their family
and their friends as they begin their
own journey to living in a body that
feels more like their home beginning
hormone replacement therapy in January
of 24 in October 23 they asked us all to
begin using they them pronouns I cannot
help but think how they would have felt
if they had reached out to someone
sooner if my teen had chosen to speak to
one of their teachers and ask them to
use they them pronouns before they were
ready to ask me to use new pronouns I
can say with confidence that I would
have felt incredibly thankful for the
support of their teachers being able to
share who you are with the world is
incredibly important to all human beings
feeling accepted and uplifted by others
when sharing who we are is one of the
healthiest experiences we can have of as
people having the support accessible in
any and every way is essential to
allowing all people to thrive in their
own lives as a parent I do not feel
threatened or negated by others
supporting my children I am grateful
every day that each of them feel the
love that others may have for them and I
wish this for all the little people in
the granite
state I heard my
time thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee thanks for coming today thank
Mr chair and members of the committee
thank you very much for having me here
to testify I'm Michelle VY the executive
director of New Hampshire businesses for
social responsibility we represent
businesses and organizations across the
state that create jobs products and
services that support the residents of
the State of New Hampshire our employees
their family Ames and and their friends
are members of the lgbtq plus Community
we know that it's important for each of
us to feel safe and in control of our
personal lives and to be valued for our
authentic selves our businesses and our
workplaces are constrained we are having
a tough time finding enough employees to
be productive businesses within the
state we are also businesses and you can
see by the letter that you hold in your
hand we are businesses that care very
deeply about having inclusive um
environments for our employees and
inclusive environments for their
families we therefore stand in
opposition to SB
341 we hope to continue to thrive and
grow as companies in the state but we
are troubled by the drum beat a proposed
legislation in the state house that
unfairly targets lgbtq individuals
particularly transgender youth these
bills aim to limit access to services
and support for for these children to be
able to talk to a trusted adult so I
hope that you will reconsider if you are
considering voting in favor of this
reconsider that all of our residents
have rights and that we should not
Advance discriminatory measures against
any of our residents thank you very much
thank you very much are there questions
from the
committee yes representa Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you taking my question
certainly could you comment about the
impact of legislation similar to this in
other community in other states rather
that have passed this kind of leg
legislation how it has economically
affected say North
Carolina um so I'm assuming you're
talking about the bathroom bill in North
Carolina there are several States um and
it's it's a concern of ours I didn't
want to go directly to the money side of
things but it definitely impacts um the
economy of the state going forward
because there are several organizations
you can go online and there are hundreds
of Executives from National companies
that have signed um letters of support
saying that they will not they support
the
lgbtq uh plus community and that they
will not hold events in states where
there is um there are laws that act
against or discriminate against certain
members of the community that is an
issue that we are very concerned about
because of our workforces we live as you
know New England is a small region where
our our people can easily transfer or go
to other states in their job and so to
to have a state that has an image that
is regressive and and pushes back on
certain people within our in in our
environment is not healthy for business
we want to have diverse work forces and
we hope that um by having those divver
diverse workforces we can continue to
see Innovation that is allowed by that
safety that everyone feels both within
their communities and within their
workforces and we feel it's important
that New Hampshire maintain the status
that was created back in 2018 when
governor sununu and the Republican
legislature promised to have safy
safeguards for everyone in our economy
including the trans Community thank you
uh represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here to answer these questions
I'd like to follow up just a little bit
on the on the last response you just
gave I just want to be clear uh are you
testifying that there are Financial
concerns from either NOS or perhaps
sanctions by other states or the federal
government that that are a negative
economic uh impact should legislation
like this pass there has been pass
legislation impact in this session where
there were um potential Financial
impacts but um I'm not specifically
speaking to that when I speak about
other states what I'm saying is that
there are organizations that hold
conventions um or hold um uh corporate
uh meetings so bring together all of
their employees from various locations
um that there is an economic impact when
a state has laws that um discriminate
against certain people in our
environment
further questions from the committee
represent dry thank you just a technical
question on your handout there's some
that are bold some that are asteris some
that have bold and asterisk but it
doesn't say what oh I
apologize um that's when um my
communications person didn't put this
together I did and that's why there's it
indicates companies with over a 100
employees sorry either bold or asteris
okay there's some that have both and
some that just have bold and some that
okay that's me I I apologize for not
clearly identifying that thank you thank
you for your clarification from the
committee thank you very much thank you
Chester thank you
committee thank you committee chair
thank you committee me Members my name
is Russ anchester I am a resident of
Bedford New Hampshire I'm a former
educator a former child protective
service worker and a former s social
worker um so I came here today to talk
about the big issue um which is bottom
line let's not promote
deception and untruths to our children
children learn what they live if we as a
teacher as a social worker as a child
protective service worker if we help to
deceive parents what do we modeling to
secrets a 15-year-old is having a sexual
relationship with an 18-year-old and the
parent says you're not allowed to see
that person so the parent writes a
letter to the school and says is this
going on well teacher doesn't want to be
a
tattletail is that okay because if that
15-year-old gets pregnant it's the
parents that are going to be financially
responsible and it will be that
18-year-olds P 18-year-old who will
become a sexual offend on potentially
become on the sexual offender list for
the rest of their life that's the kind
of impact not passing this bill will
have for the the people of New Hampshire
I listened to a lot of people at I
didn't even know that the transgender
issue was going to come up and I'll be
honest with you the bottom line is is as
a social worker as someone who studied
psychology um unfortunately perpetrators
seek out their victims where they are
most likely to not get caught and to
have
access so when I hear confidentiality
I'm almost done when I hear conf
confidentiality is an issue between
between teacher and student your your
time is up that's concerning I would
hope that people pay attention to the
people that are speaking in opposition
to this bill and do your research on
what their intent is behind that
opposition are there any questions from
the committee not see thank you very
uh good morning M good morning Mr
chairman for the record Brian Hawkins
representing Nea New
Hampshire um parents and Educators have
been working well together for a long
time in the state and we should be
passing bills to further support this
relationship and not fracture it with uh
confusing and intimidating legislation
such as Senate Bill 341 it was mentioned
earlier that the teacher shortage
committee report found that quote
classroom teachers are feeling and
Reporting stress and concerns for a
consequence as a result of legislation
proposed and pass in our state house um
and that is resulting in teachers
leaving the profession we feel that this
bill would fit right in with that type
of legislation it should be asked uh
what are people seeking to achieve by
passing this legislation that cannot be
accomplished today uh as I mentioned
Educators welcome the discussion and
questions about how their child is doing
in their class from parents um if
there's an answer to a question given by
a teacher that somehow unsatisfactory to
a parent of a student um then they have
recourse through their principal and
through established processes in the
school I'm going to skip over to keep uh
to my time um couple of key questions I
just wanted to mention first who in the
in the bill language who is the AR of
what is material information uh or
whether an inquiry is answered
completely or not during the Senate uh
hearing even the Department of Education
testified that honestly and completely
standard was subjective uh and would be
difficult to enforce and I urge you to
look at the senate committee report uh
which outlines that um in that um
attorney F advised that the complete and
honest standard was unclear in its
origin seemed subjective and difficult
to force and that's from the senate
committee report um the that language
has not changed from the way the Senate
amended the bill secondly uh completely
and honestly to the extent permitted by
state or federal law I'll wrap up is
also concerning be regarding the
position the educator is placed in here
so now an educator juggling competing
interests determining what is material
and then deciding what is a complete
answer and whether too much detail
violates some state or federal law that
they may not be aware of and at a
determination whether a complete
disclosure might risk their students
safety
and do you have that written is that
written testim I do have some written
testimony that I was referencing yes
okay thank you I'm happy to hand that
make sure that we get one up here yes
thank you questions from the committee
yes representa dry thank you thank you
for taking my commit uh question um I do
have a question about a place where you
can't get information if you ask and our
school in my district has two policies
one is the jbab policy that says gender
identity is not revealed unless to to
anyone including the parents unless the
the student agrees and the other is a
form to fill out about gender identity
that has lists your pronouns and name
but does not require a parent signature
just a faculty or staff signature and a
and a and a student signature so I'm I'm
wondering if that falls in the category
of information that could be asked for
that wouldn't be
given I think those
issues fall under different bills that
this legislature has rejected actually
um and so uh again one of the concerns
around this bill is that this is not
just addressing uh what is allowable and
not allowable under a Schoolboard policy
this goes directly to the educator uh
and and goes bypasses uh a typical
process that a school employee would
follow if they're trying to if there's a
question they're like I'm not sure about
this um that they would follow this this
puts the the pressure the impetus solely
on the
educator yes okay so the person you're
asking saying I don't know about you're
talking about the teacher would have
process thank you thank you further
questions from the committee represent
Woodcock thank you Mr Hawkins for being
here um I like to go back to a phrase
you said is where make sure have
accurate you were talking about the
Senate report testimony it's already
been recorded and and you stated who
spoke this phrase and I just trying to
get back to that hear quite well and it
was that the phraseology of complete and
honest is
unclear um where did that come from sure
um so in the Senate hearing um that came
from the Department um in when you look
at at the Senate report and and my uhu
my written testimony references this as
well um the the testimony that day was
given by um attorney Fenton at the
department for the Department of
Education yes thank you sir you're
welcome any further
questions have a good day thank you very
much uh Lisa
Kagel I hope I'm saying it right is that
good morning um good morning my name is
Lissa Kagel I am a educator a lifelong
educator and um thank you for hearing my
testimony today I um I didn't prepare
anything formal I wanted to mention uh I
am I have worked in four states uh as as
an educator a speech language
pathologist and uh when I came to New
Hampshire a couple years back I was told
I had to take a suicide prevention
course for students I have never had to
take that before I know of course we
have to do child abuse reporting etc etc
um and I learned that New Hampshire has
a higher rate of suicide than other
states and that was uh alarming to me
working with children seeing that that's
a real risk um and then I learned that
um lgbtq plus children are at an even
increased risk of for suicide based on
the Discrimination they face on a daily
basis so as a person in the classroom
well in my workplace I don't have my own
classroom um I feel concerned for my
students that I know
personally if this
passes will affect them will affect
people that I know very intimately and I
wanted to publicly State my opposition
to SB
341 thank you are there questions from
the
committee thank you you uh Lynn curer
Stanley
uh thank you to the committee for
hearing my testimony for the record my
name is Lyn cier Stanley I am a social
worker and I'm the executive director of
the National Association of Social
Workers New Hampshire chapter and I I
live here in conquer uh we are in
opposition to se uh Senate Bill
341 uh social workers who work in the
school are also certified they fall
under this category um and our our
primary concern is that this if this
were to become law it puts a
law in the middle of best
practice it acts against best practice
if a student is in danger
confidentiality goes out the
window if a
student confides in a teacher a social
work worker a nurse anyone who's
certified within the
school and then the parents reach out to
that
individual If the child is not ready to
talk and it is let's be clear it is
developmentally appropriate for
adolescents to seek out other trusted
adults before or in lie of talking to
their own parents it takes out any of
that ability for the social worker or
the teach
to be able to say I think you should
talk to your child about this or to work
with that that student to get ready to
talk to the to their parents I will I'm
keeping my testimony brief I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee thank you again uh Roger blue
blow no blow blow thank you
thank you for hearing
me
oops I'm probably the oldest guy here I
live in New Hampshire all my life I'm 76
years old I was homophobic before my
daughter came out to me when I was 44 so
she probably told teachers and stuff uh
that she was it was not to my knowledge
and I'm glad that it was because I
probably wasn't ready took me three
years of counseling and now I I support
lgbtq I go to gay pride parades Etc uh
to me outing a person is the worst thing
anybody can do with somebody that's
that's terrible terrible for them it's
psychologically terrible you cannot do
that if you really care about children
or even adults that don't want to be out
it you cannot do that that harms them
like nothing else you can do to them so
I urge that you vote against this bill
uh to me children are trying to figure
out who they are and where they belong
curiosity of sexual orientation sexual
identity gender identity expression the
true crisis of belonging place where
they can feel and feel safe and belong
and I know a lot of people talked about
teachers ver versus parents it should be
kind of both but I think teachers are
certified they have all kinds of kids
that they have to deal with from Liberal
to conservative from one religion to
another religion they have to deal with
all of them and they they know how to do
it and they I really believe in them as
a matter of fact when you think of it
Jesus was called teacher I really
believe in teachers and I think they
mean the best of course there's I can
always give you uh incidences of where
teachers were bad but I can do the same
thing with priests and boy scout leaders
etc etc you know to me generally
teachers are fine they mean well and uh
I I dealt in literally where a kid I had
a lot of problems with him I went to see
the father when I met the father I knew
right away that kid would get beaten if
I complained about him so I just said oh
he's a good kid so they're not parents
are not all perfect teachers are not all
perfect but in general they're trained
on how to take care of people so uh this
is not the age of uh Leave It to Beaver
parents and all like that and and also
what if parents a divorce is a teacher
required to tell every parent mix mixed
marriages um to me that's all but you
cannot hurt people like this do not do
that to people please uh the other thing
I want to tell you as I uh I'm a Vietnam
veteran I I was attached to the green
berad for a year in Vietnam and I fought
for freedom for everybody including
lgbtq so please keep that in mind thank
you very much Roger and thank you for
your service okay any questions from the
committee
chz good morning honorable members of
the committee I'm Remy Jac a high school
senior from Newbury here to testify
against HB or SB 341 I'm wish to bring
attention to the fact that those who
would be most affected by this bill
children in unsafe home environments who
cannot come out at home are unable to be
here to testify against this bill
ideally all parents would care for their
children and support them for who they
are but we do not live in a perfect
world I've had friends who have been
driven to the brink of suicide from
verbal abuse from their parents but who
have been able to live on because of
their ability to live their true selves
and connect with those at school parent
teachers friends CPS intervention is
rarely called in against verbal abuse
primarily against physical abuse but for
lgbtq youth suicide is the greatest risk
and suicide is something primarily
driven by emotional and verbal
problems they cannot be here today
because some of them are not allowed to
leave their home and go places without
direct permission from their parents so
I urge you to protect those who are
unable to be here to protect themselves
today thank you are there a questions
yes represent
Woodcock good afternoon um did you say
you're a high school senior yes thank
further questions from the
committee thank
Caston good morning um sales Casten uh
with New Hampshire youth movement from
Dober New Hampshire um school should be
a place for for teaching and learning
and not surveillance uh teachers should
be focused on the material and in making
their classrooms good environments that
are focused on growth and students
should be focused on learning um and we
think that uh SB 341 um does not promote
that environment um since teachers are
mandated reporters this bill does not
protect uh a child's safety it allows a
vehicle of abuse uh and distrust between
teachers and students uh school is often
space as we've already heard from for
lgbtq students to have an opportunity to
live as their authentic selves um if
their home does not allow them to do so
um and many teachers across New
Hampshire serve as a safe person to talk
to uh and for students to express
themselves to uh and parents already
have the comfort of knowing that those
teachers are required to disclose any
dangerous activity any activity which
could be harming their children or or
allowing their children to harm others
uh thanks to mandated reporting but
outside of danger uh those students have
the freedom of exploring and presenting
themselves how they how they want to uh
and they also have the freedom to choose
uh when they want to talk to their
parents about certain subjects um so I
could go on but I think I'll keep it
short for now but uh I in strong
opposition of s SP 342 thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee thank
you uh Christina Kim
she
here how do you say your last name
Christina
philipo phot you have the best
penmanship of anybody here in the
room I I just had a hard time with a
name I appreciate that like a lot right
my parents have beautiful penmanship and
um you have wonderful manuscript there
wonderful thank you go
ahead um yes so my name is Tina Kim Fila
um I wanted to say that just to prepare
you I'm going to be emotional but it
just kind of came so fast so I apologize
for
that
um I'm one of the four um diversity
Equity
inclusion and Justice administrators in
the state I work um I'm the first Chief
Equity officer in the Manchester School
District but I'd like to be clear I am
here in my individual capacity as a
citizen
as as an
Mom I'll start by saying I firmly oppose
this
bill
um so I'm one of those certified
Educators in the state I have a
certification in English and also in
dance uh my job as a teacher is and was
to listen to students to provide a space
for kids to find themselves to learn
what it means to become a trusted
Confidant in their future relationships
we model that for kids when we listen
well as a dance educator I'm proud to
say that ours was the first concert
Dance Program one of the first concert
dance dance programs in the state one of
the first things I did when we started
the program so it would be successful is
to recruit folks yeah so I recruited the
um from the two largest um athletic
teams right football and track yeah and
I'm really uh you know Dance is for
girls is what they said and Dance is for
boys that are you know they wouldn't say
that out loud to me because they knew
better I had the whole starting lineup
in arnut Cracker the first
year because we were able to have open
conversations and we were able to break
barriers that just have existed in these
spaces for much too
long
um I'm going to also add
um I have been that one trusted teacher
for a lot of kids I've had thousands of
students um in my 15-year career as a
teacher I've received letters after
they've graduated met up with them to
today because of the experiences they
they had the conversations we were able
to have and because they knew though
they had yet to come out at that point
cared I'm also a parent of an adult
child um 21 um and they are a part of
the
lgbtqia
community when my child was in sixth
grade I had a parent teacher conference
yeah and the the teacher was telling me
about how my child was um really into
advocacy great student great reader um
gay just dropped it right
there I did not know that I did not know
that and let me tell you I'm a
progressive person right I'm pretty my
my um Reagan Republican father calls me
a bleeding heart of bleeding
hearts and uh it took me offg guard I
wasn't expecting to hear that I look
back on that moment in hindsight um you
know I think the teacher thought that I
knew because of who I am because of who
we are it's just that I didn't and she
took the opportunity for my child to
share the single most important part of
their identity that they were grappling
with in that moment from my child and
from our family it was a private
conversation that my child should have
been able to have had on their own time
with their own agency with their mother
who loves and cares about them your time
is
up do you want to conclude or um I just
I feel like
um I appreciate I appreciate your time
but I wanted to make sure that that was
clear I also want to add one more thing
if that's okay go ahead okay um you know
my child is from the lgbtq community in
terms of intersection right also uh a
Korean as well um when we talk about
waited in the emergency room with my
bed and I had a conversation with my
child before I came here to have this
conversation you know growing up in New
Hampshire is hard and when laws like
this made by adults like you come out it
tells people and it tells kids that who
they are doesn't matter it tells them
that people don't care about them that
matter their mental health is deeply
affected and they don't have the
capacity and in that
moment to be a they just F this child
who has this parent didn't feel like
they had the capacity to come to me in
that moment because it was
beyond it was they just would say we I
just couldn't handle
it mom I know you love
alive as a
teacher and I think about what that
teacher
did to my
child it's already hard enough as it is
as a kid to have and to find that
identity to take that away from them
right to be in environments where people
don't accept
them it adds up and it looks like what
it looked like for our family my child
is a young adult now and continues to
struggle with mental
health there is a consequence there is a
money you go to a hospital you have to
bring things every single time there are
co-pays every single
time my child is since moved out of New
Hampshire because they don't feel like
this is a welcoming environment for
them I think we're going to have to call
it right there okay thank you very very
much other questions from the
house okay good morning chairman lad and
members of the committee good to see you
again uh I am here to testify on SB 341
I am deor house president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire I'm here on behalf of our 3700
members across the state we mostly work
in K12 uh education we are also parents
grandparents and taxpayers in New
Hampshire and um I am here to
unequivocally oppose s SP
341 and we oppose this bill because
simply put it is not in the best
interest of our
students we are always happy to discuss
with parents classwork homework uh
academics whether a student is behaving
following the school rules whether
they're kind to other
students but uh we oppose this bill
because it will create a climate of fear
in our schools for educators and for our
students that complete and honest
standard that in the bill that the um
Prime sponsors said was so easy to
understand when you start looking into
it it really could go very far there's
no limit on the question a parent could
ask so what does the individual educator
have to keep track of there's nothing
there that tells you you know you just
have to keep track of all their
assignments and what you're teaching or
um you know whether they're possibly
bullying other any other students you
have to keep track of everything the
student says to you everything do you
have to keep track of everything you
hear them say to other students as
they're passing in the hallway how about
everything they're wearing changes in
hairstyle um are they suddenly dressing
in a fashion that is different you know
more feminine more masculine do I have
to keep track of that uh By the way when
I'm writing all this down because if I
don't answer completely and honestly I'm
going to have a consequence I might lose
my license uh when do I have time to
teach reading yeah where's the academics
in this you create a climate of fear
among the Educators because they are
afraid they don't um answer completely
and honestly and then you create a
climate of fear amongst students I will
just finish this last point very quickly
um because they know that everything
they say and do whether dealing directly
with a teacher or with other students at
school amongst their peers can and will
be reported back to their parents so
they have no chance to actually be a
child and grow and be independent human
beings like they're meant to be so we
urge you to itl this bill and I will be
sending the um testimony in email to you
thank you very much other
questions thank you oh R Dr you had your
hand up thank you just thank you for
taking the question I I understand
there's no limit on number of questions
I'm just ask wondering is I don't know
or I haven't heard anything a complete
and honest answer that would work from
the testimony I heard in the Senate bill
and testimony I heard this morning it is
assumed that if it happens at school the
schooled employee must know the answer
otherwise you're withholding information
and lying and I find that a very
offensive assumption but I have heard
that several times already today I heard
it repeatedly in the sen testimony so I
would be very concerned and all my
members are concerned that we'll be
assumed to be lying if we don't know the
answer or don't go find the answer out
and and that's a horrible position to
put us in because we'd actually rather
be teaching our
students further questions from the
um hi there um I'm in opposition to um
Bill
341 um I uh was homeschooled in a
Conservative Christian Community um K
through2 in New Hampshire um and then
went to a private Conservative Christian
College so from birth to age 22 I was
part of a community um that would inform
on you that would report um to your
parents to church leadership to
educators
um if you were outed um as LGBT lgbtq
plus um and uh so I I can tell you um
that this culture of of reporting um it
undermines trust um it creates fear
shame um you know like you can't express
yourself and and just the amount of of
trauma that that does to a young brain
um it it's it's huge um I'm now I'm a
social worker I'm a mental health
professional in a high school with a
specialization in lgbtq plus youth um
and it's my goal to be the safe adult
that I needed to be um as as a queer
youth as a mental health professional um
I'm I'm concerned um about how as a
mental health professional school I'm
concerned about how this bill um is
going to impact like the confid the
confidentiality um you know
responsibility ities um that I have as a
mental health professional um and and
this bill just does not support the
science of attachment and caregiver
child relationships which which has to
be built on trust and autonomy of the
child to share in their own time um as
we've heard in other testimonies um I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
are there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
[Music]
yeah thank you chair lad thank you
members of the committee my name is
Chris urel and I'm an attorney with glad
I'm New Hampshire licensed um today this
committee is looking at yet another bill
that seeks to force teachers and other
school Personnel into an unprecedented
surveillance role in our schools once
again I'm here to say that this bill is
unworkable invasive and dangerous two
courts with binding Authority in New
Hampshire are currently considering
cases involving people who claim that
schools have a constitutional obligation
to Monitor and report on how their
children identify at school one case out
of L Massachusetts is pending in the
first circuit the other is the
Manchester case uh pending in the New
Hampshire Supreme Court it is unlikely
that either Court will establish a new
constitutional obligation to report on
how students identify at school while
the bill sponsors rais raises the issue
of uh the rights of parents this concern
is misplaced we must remember that
nobody can or should stop a parent from
asking important questions from having
sensitive conversations and from
instilling their values with their
children at home teachers and other
school Personnel want a strong
relationship between students and
parents it's in everyone's best interest
to encourage open communication and
schools can be really powerful allies in
providing resources to students and to
parents to Foster and support open
communication this legislation would
actually undermine that crucial role
that schools can play play in supporting
families courts have told us however
that young people do have a qualified
right to Pro privacy and how they
identify almost 30 years ago two young
men in Pennsylvania were found by a
police officer parked in a car at night
that officer threatened to share
information with the family of one of
the young men Marcus Wayman and
tragically he took his life that night
because he was not ready for his family
to know that he was gay his parents sued
the police department for threatening to
disclose and the court of appeals at for
the third circuit said that it does
violate the constitutional rights of a
young person when a government official
threatens to disclose personal
information to their families when that
disclosure could cause harm honest and
complete complete is a moving Target and
it's up to the whim of any individual to
say that information provided by a
teacher is incomplete because of any
detail that was not remembered or
recorded and
shared
um I just want to make one really quick
point that there there's no delineation
in this bill between direct observation
versus indirect speculation even though
the sponsor said otherwise uh teachers
don't lie to parents if that's a concern
shared by legislators in New Hampshire I
would invite you to consider legislation
that prohibits false representations to
parents that's not what this bill does
this bill inserts teachers into family
Affairs a role that they're not trained
or prepared to take on I'm happy to take
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative
Woodcock good almost good afternoon good
morning can you just clarify for me in
very simple lay terms um your statement
about the qualified right of
confidentiality uh qualified right of
privacy uh meaning that if uh that Court
have said that a student or sorry that a
young person um might have a right to
not have their information
constitutionally protected right under
the 14th Amendment to not have personal
information about them disclosed to
their family members when the government
official who has that information has
reason to suspect that it might result
in harm to that young person thank
you any further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you for your time I have no
further pin cards on this bill so I'm
hearing okay and the committee is going
repres okay the committee is going to
take a break break and we're going to
reconvene at
12:30 and we will come back at that time
you
e
good afternoon to everybody we are ready
to continue our hearing hearings today
this is the last hearing of the day uh
SB
375 this is Bill relative B to
biological sex and student Athletics and
I'd like to welcome represent Senator
Lang thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee I'm Senator Tim
Lang from the Lakes Region I cover
Senate District 2 um I'm here for Senate
aard who is unfortunately feeling ill
and could not make it to introduce this
bill so um this bill is a pretty
straightforward bill I I'm just going to
make a couple preliminary statements and
first there's nowhere in this bill will
you you see the word gender this bill is
not about gender this bill is about
biological sex so what the bill does is
basically say that biological females
will play on the fem Sports identified
as female biological males will play on
sport Sports designated as a male and we
don't care who plays on coed Sports if
you have a sport identified as co-ed um
it excludes out a couple things so again
the issue around the the science and and
puberty um and biological Advantage
starts at puberty and so therefore this
doesn't apply to K through five classes
because they haven't reached puberty yet
so it doesn't they don't have a a
physiological Advantage um the other
thing we took out was uh Co um
co-curricular or inter mural in club
sports in colleges again these are
voluntary these are not uh you don't get
scholarships to play on the club sport
you don't get scholarships to play on
you mural Sports and again part of this
bill is about opportunities and the
availability for biological females to
be able to have opportunities in the in
the in the in education so that's what
the bill doesn't do but again the bill
is pretty straightforward it says
biological males will play on biological
male Sports biological females will play
on female sports the reason is why would
we do this what is the what is the
causation around this so we've
identified basically three things this
build seeks to address safety for our
biological females fairness for our
biological females and opportunity for
our biological females so those are the
three key points and I'll talk about
each point so we talk about safety what
safety problem does this does does
allowing a trans female or biological
male to play in a female sport or a
biological female sport the answer is it
creates injury right so I don't have to
go very far we can just go right down to
to Massachusetts where most recently
there was a a female a basketball team
on the other opposing side was a trans
male three female students were injured
before finally the coach decided to
Forfeit the game rather than continue
playing the game um because of a
biological male that was playing on the
female team for the opposing team um we
can go to um 2023 last year in
Massachusetts uh we had the incident
involving field hockey where again a
biological male playing in a in a
biological female SP in a female sport
um ended up causing injury to a player
knocking their teeth out in field hockey
um because of the um the strength at
which they use the uh I don't know what
they call the stick um but a stick um we
can go to 2022 in California um
volleyball um there was a trans female
student playing on a female sports team
who spiked the ball so hard into the
face of a biological female that she's
still hasn't been cleared to return to
sports due to neurological and issues
with her spine and then
2021 um there was another incident in
Massachusetts surrounding round
basketball so this is the safety Factor
right when when a biological female goes
to play sports they expect they're going
to be on an even playing field and that
uh um and that they'll be able to
compete at at a relative basis so that
steps into the fairness argument so when
we talk about fairness why is it unfair
why is it unfair to him to have a trans
female play in um a female sport so just
in uh 929 of 23 the American College of
sports medicine says biological sex is
the determinant factor in in athletic
performance because of the fundamental
sex differences in anatomy so that's a
fairness argument right
biologically post pesent boys have
strong have have are stronger have
higher muscle density and actually even
um in their uh lung capacity or lung uh
sorry I'm going to try to I'm going to
say this wrong but the oxygen to blood
reaction man are different in the way
that in the way that oxygen is absorbed
that gives them a physiological
Advantage so we're talking about
physiological advantage
that boys have biological boys have when
playing sports and is it fair to have
our daughters our biological female
daughters be subjected to that
unfairness and my postulation is no the
last one is opportunity again just
recently 124 of 23 the University of
Washington offered uh one of only 12
female scholarships for volleyball to a
trans male athlete so taking away the 12
female that could have gotten a college
scholarship and we all depending on
which side of the aisle you'll argue
that again access to higher education
results in better um performance in the
job market right so again here's a
biological girl on the girls volleyball
team that was denied a scholarship in a
D1 team um in favor of a trans female
taking away the opportunity we talk a
lot about Title 9 and I noticed recently
Title 9 was was morphed um into gender
equal sex but I'll explain to you that
in the medical practice that's not true
in medical science gender and sex are
two inter two different things um sex is
segmented differently because of the
physiological advantages that we just
talked about and and and there are
diseases that are available to men that
aren't available to women and there are
diseases for women that are not
available to men and that's the
biological factor and so even in medical
science they delineate between gender
which is your expression and sex which
is your chromosomes so this bill seeks
to say that um again B Bas on your
um birth certificate at issued at or or
near birth um you'll play on the
appropriates team based on that so we
don't have issues of fairness uh safety
or reduction of opportunity for our
female uh biological female daughters
I'm happy to take questions thank you
very much Senator uh are there questions
from the
committee represent are you handing up
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my
question I'm for Fe 11 tall I will never
be able to compete with most women on
most sports are we going to write a bill
that says only people who are above a
certain height you're making it on
physical attributes that I wouldn't pass
in anything except maybe
poker so I'm wondering how far are we
going to be taking this and and
marginalizing groups of people based on
physical attributes thank you for your
question so again I'm going to go back
to Nowhere in this bill is gender in
this bill right we're not talking about
Expos or going against anybody of gender
we're talking about biological sex and
why again science about biological sex
and how that creates a physiological
Advantage so again um I I don't play
basketball well I I'm 5 foot eight right
it's an acceptance I have right um and I
acknowledge that and I don't think I
should be given a special benefit
because I'm 5 fo8 and I should
automatically have a spot on the
basketball team right that's not that's
not uh something I would expect but
again biological female the whole point
of the original title 9 signed over 50
years ago was to create an equal playing
field because women could not find a
place on a male sports team because of
physiological advantages and so Title
Nine which was was was
I I recently found out that Vice uh
President Nixon was the one that signed
that and and I went to I was visiting
his Museum when I was down uh out in
California and it was heralded as a fund
one of the fundamental changes of the
women's rights movement at the time it
was issued because it created an equal
playing field between male athletes and
female athletes and allowed for that
functionality we've now we've now um and
so this bill just seeks to recognize
that that FAL inquality that was
recognized back in 1973 I think it was
this bill just seeks to recognize that
and and put it in law follow one
question please yes Title Nine which I
have read was not about equal it was
about equal money for women's sports it
didn't care who was on the teams what it
cared about was what money was spent for
the teams so it had nothing really to do
with genders or sex or anything like
that delineated but so again it uses the
word sex in the bill not gender right in
that title 9 language it uses the word
lineation any other questions
representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for being here and presenting
this um you've youve told us that the
primary motivation behind pursuing this
bill is to prevent injury to to female
athletes that's something I'm incredibly
inclined to agree with but given that
I'm a little bit curious as to item six
here that says any team sport or
athletic event designated for males men
or boys shall be open to students of
either sex so I'm wondering what the
rationale is for allowing girls than to
play with boys under those circumstances
and if you wouldn't mind also speaking
to what's to prevent schools from Simply
designating all teams Boys in order to
get around
this thank you for your question so
again the initial reason was for for
allowing that is that when a biological
female goes to play on the female team
they have a certain amount of
expectations about safety and fairness
and what's going to happen and the
opportunities they may have if they
choose again so remember the choice to
go play on a boys team and we've had
that right here in conquer right there
was a hockey player back several 20
years ago at Muny I think her name was
um who chose to play in the boys hockey
team and actually went to Olympics on
the girls hockey team um in uh for New
Hampshire um and so the idea was if a if
a girl chooses to step into that they
have that right to choose to play I want
to play I want to be a kicker on the
football team right and they have the
right to at least go and try out right
but to have a male who has a
physiological Advantage come into the
female sport creates a a a fundamental
unfairness and also raises safety
concerns further questions from the
represent Miler thank you thank you for
taking my
question are you familiar have you met
with the TR any trans family and
reviewed for them the process that the
family goes
through uh the hormonal changes the
psychological issues that the family
goes through or that trans
female to be able to basically change
her own phys physicality and I've done
that I've talked with them this is not a
um this is not a willy-nilly decision
that a family makes as you may know this
is a very serious decision it takes time
over the years for this transition to
take place and yet when that happens my
question to you is have first of all
have you met with trans families and
understand what that process is yes then
you also know then at that point in time
there is a physical change that does
take place in that individual and what
you're trying to say here in this bill
is that that change
is going to be mitigated by this bill
and disallow that individual from
playing in a sport that they choose
to thank if I just ask a clarifying
question are you talking about a student
a child who takes puberty blockers yes
okay great thank you for bringing that
point up so again I'm going to go back
to science because that's been a lot of
my uh reasoning around this bill is
science so again on 312 of 24 the
National Health Institute of England
concluded that there's not enough
evidence to support the safety or
clinical effectiveness of puberty
blockers so they stopped Physicians from
prescribing so understand that emerging
Medical Science says that this is not
irreversible right that giving a child
child puberty blockers that has a
long-term impact and medical science is
as emerging Medical Science recognizes
that and is withdrawing that as a
treatment
program further questions from the
committee Thank you very much represent
representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so if the Paramount reason that
this bill is proposed is for
safety uh I have two questions one why
then are you exempting club and
intermural sports if those are I'll stay
with your terminology for the moment
mixed sex teams wouldn't the safety
issues be the same thank you for the
question you those are voluntary so
again if someone's choosing High School
sports are voluntary excuse me if I can
finish my answer thank you so again club
sports and intermural sports are
voluntary there's no obligation you
don't get a college scholarship for it
so you're not taking away an opportunity
for anybody and again if um a biological
female chooses to step on the field it's
the same reason why the representative
bel's point I we allowed females to play
in male Sports if they choose to step on
the field they know what they're getting
into when I choose to step when when a b
iCal female goes to sign up for female
sports they expect there's going to be a
fundamental safety um there and there's
going to be fundamental fairness there
and by allowing a trans female on the
team you potentially take away both
those things never mind the long-term
issue of of
opportunity questions yes thank
you and so following from that then what
would be your response to the reality
that the primary variable in someone's
strength and capacity in any sport on
the field the court wherever is their
conditioning and training and their
wherewith all to play so how does that
factor into this sure thank you for the
question again um I go back to the
American College of Sportsmen's
statement biological sex is the
determinant factor of of athletic
performance is a I'm sorry biological
sex is a determinant of athletic
performance because of the fundamental
sex differences in anatomy so again the
the answer to your question is you have
an fundamental unfairness happening when
a biological male participates in a
female
WX good afternoon one day uh a couple
things I want to go back to the
estatement you made uh to represent
Damon about club sports um similar to
other high school sports they are
voluntary kids do participate but often
club
sports are not
in vity at JB level because they don't
have that status yet so it's not
necessarily that they can't earn a
scholarship the youngsters don't have a
chance to earn a scholarship is that
most school systems you said you're a
school teacher somewhere I didn't catch
what you said you thought but most
school
systems um require that schools because
of budgetary considerations do start
kids with club sports and then Mo JD
program V program so if that if that
sport is the first time at that school
and often though that's the only
opportunity for youngsters so it could
be very well an opportunity for
athletics so it's just it was sort of
just want to correct your your frame on
that and the representative my is
exactly correct on on Title Nine h i was
happen to be a benefit a benefactor of
Title 9 actually because of the pay um
that it does provide equal opportunity
for work and pay team scheduling team
sports those types of things uh it
wasn't looking at when it came through
with the participation piece so uh I
guess my concern is the club sports are
actually feeders to to high school
programs my question is um and you said
scholarship about how many how many high
school scholar how how many kids get
division one scholarships to play high
school ball oh it's very fractional
again it's fractional um of the number
of students I'm assuming again that get
division W Scholarships in New Hampshire
again but even one taken away would be
wrong okay and just the and on your I'm
confused if I may it's the last question
thank you Mr chair uh line 23 through 26
I don't I don't understand the need to
say that because you're not prohibiting
uh you're prohibiting people from
playing you're prohibiting from kids to
have opportunity to play but you're
saying that that uh I doesn't say they
have to go to that bathroom I'm Sor I
don't quite understand which I I I I'm
you have to tell me the section 29 29
line 23 through 27 it talks about
facilities instead of a school school do
high school or even a college here I
don't know why you're trying to tell the
NCA what to do but if they're having
these facilities then they have to have
one for male one for female biological
sex do you know of any high school or
college or Community College in New
Hampshire that doesn't have a male and a
female bathroom in the lockal facilities
one so every High School I've ever been
in has a both a male and female yeah um
correct I mean every every Public Public
University or School in New Hampshire
has one of those so I don't understand
why that does even in there oh thank you
so the answer is on the last line of 26
that shall provide separate facilities
for male and female participants based
on biological sex so again if you thank
you if I can finish my question um so
again the idea being that biological
boys will use the biological boys room
the biological girls use the biological
girls room because they're undressing
and getting ready for sport getting
ready for a physical activity and so the
I that doesn't say that rson Woodcock
would you please let him finish before
then if you have want to be have another
question please get recognized for the
question do you have anything else
further on that Senator I'm fine thank
you I just okay you have thank you sh
yes it doesn't say that it doesn't say
they have to go to that bathroom it just
says every school has to have one which
they already have that's all just the
point Thank you further further
questions says represent Miler yeah I'd
like to just thank you I'd like to
follow up on uh represent woodcock is it
so it's your testimony then you as I
heard you right that there are a
fractional amount of people who are
eligible for scholarships is that
correct no I didn't say scholarships the
question was D1 which is a very high
standard but D2 schools can also we have
an increased number of those as a matter
of fact I believe son of the ganon's
daughter is a recipient of a D2
scholarship um for field hockey so there
are both when we add division two that
number gets significantly bigger but the
but the fractionalization of that is
then Trump's the volume of trans kids
that could participate in sports and
learn leadership learn teamwork Etc as
they have life skills that are developed
so you're saying that's more important
than allowing young people more a
greater volume of young people to
participate in sports rather than just
those who might might get a scholarship
is that correct thankes so I can answer
your question the answer the answer is
nothing in this bill stops any student
from playing sports nothing in this bill
what the bill does is say that the sport
has to be fair though right and we have
to be safe and so therefore based on
biological sex You'll Play in that sport
whether it's a biological female or
biological male so nothing stops a
biological male who identifies as a
trans female from playing on the boys
team nothing so they have the
opportunity to play okay let me ask you
this question if I'm a male and I want
to play field hockey can I play field
hockey then no why not I mean cu a
biological Advantage but let's look at
this the field hockey if you if you look
at professional field hockey it's a male
sport it's not a female sport okay we're
getting into the point where it's a
debate here I'd like to ask questions
come from the committee to the person
testifying and the response comes from
there representative
pel thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so we we're talking a
lot about scholarships but what about
the um biological females who may not
even make the team because a transgender
female identifying or transgender
identifying as female may take their
place on the team well again absolutely
so again disadvantage to our biological
daughters or biological female daughters
who are bumped from a team for a
biological male who has a defined
medical physiological
Advantage I'm not going to allow people
to have more than two questions
representative spear you've already had
more than two questions no uh further
questions from the committee thank you
very much
SEL do you want
to
Mr well he wanted uh was it him yeah
it's hold on hold on a second yeah I
well we had one that spoke to me going
down the hallway here I didn't see his
School all the school system back M
oh pass equalize your pay voice code uh
can you just hold on please we have a
person that has to get on a
plane thank you representative Chris
urel do you have to hit on get a plane
here at what time not a plane I have
have anation I have to go
to is that right off here in
up and we're we're back to the
two-minute rule thank you chair lad
members of the committee again my name
is Chris urel I am a New Hampshire
licensed attorney and I'm here
representing glad I believe this is the
fifth session in a row in which there is
at least one bill attempting to block
transgender girls from girl sports teams
today to I want to emphasize two very
recent developments that should inform
how you evaluate this bill the first
development is a decision that came down
last week from the federal court of
appeals for the fourth circuit which
governs North and South Carolina
Virginia West Virginia Maryland the
decision involves a similar Sports bill
that became a law in West Virginia at
first The District Court ruled in favor
of the state of West Virginia and said
the sports ban was valid but last Monday
the appeals court reversed that decision
and said the court was wrong and that
the sports ban is invalid this outcome
is unsurprising it's consistent with
what other courts have already said that
categorical bands on transgender girls
playing School sports on girl sports
teams violates the rights of transgender
students they single out transgender
students based on sex which is a
protected characteristic depriving them
of opportunities available to other
students this powerful fourth circuit
decision is in line with the weight of
authority in other courts including the
ninth circuit I'm happy to go into more
detail later about what the decision
said but the bottom line is that s sp37
is unlikely to survive a legal challenge
I want to share another even more recent
development the US Department of
Education released new title 9
regulations on Friday the most relevant
takeaway from the new regulations is
that title 9 views discrimination
against lgbtq students as impermissible
sex discrimination categorically denying
transgender girls opportunities to
participate in sports fits squarely in
the prohibition against discrimination
based on sex the department of Ed
released proposed guidance on Sports
specific speically which the new R say
is still forthcoming um and that'll make
it even more clear that categorical bans
on participation by transgender students
violates Title 9 this is very important
because as you know the US doe enforces
its regulations by controlling funding
New Hampshire's public schools are asked
to do more and more with less and less
the legislature must not compel schools
to violate Title 9 and risk losing
Federal funding leadership cooperation
self-disciplined Community these are the
critical skills that young people learn
from participating in school sports
programs that's why these programs are
an essential part of a complete public
education these opportunities need to be
available to every student including
transgender students and you must reject
this legislation if I had um more time I
would um talk about some of the
anecdotes that uh that the prime sponsor
raised and and um you there was some
misinformation and some lack some
missing context from those stories but
um anyway I uh will'll stop there thank
you very much Chris uh are questions
from the
committee represent Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here would you
please correct misinformation that was
cited by prior speaker um yes for first
of all uh the the uh the cast review
which was released in the United Kingdom
did not um rule that or did not make a
determination there's no determination
that uh puberty blockers are going to be
unavailable uh to to transgender PE um
people as a rule in in the United
Kingdom in fact the cast review uh
talked about how there's a need for more
research and data and
uh has has recommended that all uh
puberty blocking medications that are
prescribed in the United Kingdom be done
in the context of a clinical trial so
that more information can be collected
uh furthermore the NHS which is the
national health system in in the United
Kingdom totally doesn't really compare
to the way we manage Healthcare here in
the United States but they have
recommended uh dispersing Medical Care
um to to primary care provider teams
instead of um centralized gender clinics
and that is the thrust of what is
happening the United Kingdom it's a
misrepresentation to say that puberty
blockers have been banned um another
thing is that the basketball game
referenced in which there were three
trans three girls who are injured and a
team forfeited uh I want to make clear
that the uh there was a transgender girl
on the opposing team and uh and there
were three injuries that happened during
the game not all three were related to
the transgender student um so so that's
one piece of missing context I think is
really important another piece of
missing context is that the coach had
decided beforehand that he was down
several players and he needed to Forfeit
if there were injuries for his players
injuries happen all the time in school
sports it's the job of school officials
to ensure that sports are as safe as
possible for all students but the fact
that three students were injured in a
basketball game is unsurprising and the
coach has gone on record saying that the
presence of a transgender student is not
why he forfeited the game also no
student to my knowledge and I've
researched the issue deeply has been has
been given a scholarship to participate
uh no trans student has been given a
scholarship an athletic scholarship to
date that does not happen in any college
anywhere there's one example that's been
you know circulated around the
right-wing media of a scholarship that
was offered to a student and then either
was rescinded or uh was not accepted but
regardless never was given to this
student and that student is a volleyball
player and I can't find any confirmation
anywhere that this student is
transgender she hasn't said so herel
self her family hasn't said so so it's
speculation on the part of people in the
right-wing media trying to make a point
um and and and harm transgender people
in the process um I can leave it at that
the field hockey player who uh you know
hit the hit the ball really hard and and
broke um a female player's teeth that
was a boy he was not transgender he was
on the team because there was no other
place for him to play field hockey and
um I just I asked the committee to to
inquire as to why um if me if boys are
so dangerous to girls why aren't boys so
dangerous to other boys that they
shouldn't be allowed to play sports what
is the why why is it okay for a boy to
be hit in the face with a field hockey
ball and lose his teeth if it's not okay
for a girl too I I don't really
understand that distinction but that's
that's what I wanted to say about those
anecdotes thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee
represent
Woodcock thank you chair for taking a
question um two are you are you aware of
any of the
nhi excuse me
nhaa regulations that prohibit
transgender youngsters from playing High
School sport yeah thank you for that
question it's a very important question
I think so the in 2015 the New Hampshire
inter schoolastic Athletic Association
revised its eligibility policy um
because of a transgender New Hampshire
Public School student named Sarah
huckman who came forward and advocated
for her right to play school sports uh
the eligibility requirements prior to
2015 required that um transgender
students have surgery before they' be
eligible to participate in school sports
which you know of course is nonsensical
uh and should not be a requirement for
for for participation
so Sarah huckman was able to influence
the NHA by by you know lobbying and and
and the new policy eligibility
requirements uh put uh put put forth
what are reasonable guidelines about uh
about how and when a transgender student
can become eligible to play sports uh
nhiaa is comprised of um experts in
School athletics programs and and and
they ought to be making decisions about
eligibility uh before before uh before
the legislature should be I believe
further questions yes thank you uh are
you aware of any
NCAA rules that disallow transgender
students from participating in sport
yeah the NCAA has had a policy in place
that's been evolving over time but has
been around for over 10 years that
ensures that transgender students do
have the opportunities to participate
and play in school sports and this
legislation would override the ncaa's
policy NCAA uses evidence-based
protocols to determine what hormone
level um and what periods of time are
necessary to establish a student uh to
establish that a college student who and
I think we can all understand that
college competition is a lot different
from high school competition when it
comes to school sports but that college
uh Athletics uh you know sorry so NCAA
wants to ensure that there's
evidence-based protocols that prevent uh
uh inequitable uh unfairness on on girls
teams and so they establish um they
establish standards that are
evidence-based um related to physical uh
attributes incling hormones thank you
apprciate questions from the committee
not see you thank you very much thank
Cel thank you are you
ready you ready this time okay just
checking I don't think there's anybody
else I'm just making sure before I start
go for it thank you again my name is
representative Lauren seelig I represent
straford 10 which is the city or the
town of Durham which operates like a
city
um I have two daughters as I've
mentioned previously my girls both
played team sports there have been
allegations that have trans girls played
it will give them an unfair advantage or
that trans kids will somehow act
inappropriately in a bathroom my elder
daughter played peeee soccer with a
trans child she also took a soccer ball
to the face in a direct hit that ended
her desire to play again the person who
kicked the ball was not the transgender
girl she was too distracted it was a
cisgender kiddo who grew up to play
Varsity soccer before she left her
College both my kid both my girls swam
on the swim team they competed and
usually lost to CIS girls cisgender
girls who were a full foot taller than
them we tend to be vertically challenged
in my family their advantage was height
not gender in the locker room all the
girls changed in the toilet stalls if
they showered first they did so still in
their swimsuits because they all thought
being a naked in front of anyone was
weird plus it got the chlorine off their
swimsuits my older daughter has gotten
more than one concussion in her I'm
sorry my younger daughter has gotten
more than one concussion in her time
playing basketball and cheering in one
case she and another child both went for
the ball at the same time very
aggressively my daughter came up with
the ball the other girl came up with my
daughter's head wasn't so good for her
head um in none of these cases was it a
trans child who injured them it was just
regular girls playing Just Like Girls
play sports have inherent dangers that's
why parents have to sign releases
finally I can tell you that while I have
been sexually harassed and assaulted in
my life including in a women's bathroom
it was never by a trans person but by a
heterosexual man asserting his power and
a heterosexual man who pretends to be
trans to get into a woman's room is not
a trans woman he is a jerk and quite
possibly a criminal this bill is
discriminatory and hurtful and I implore
you to oppose it thank you very much are
there any questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
so I'm I'm represent Timothy Horan also
from straford County District 10 which
is also the town of Durham in my written
testimony which you've all seen twice
because I handed out printed copies and
put it on the web portal I haven't
emailed it to you I mentioned being a
longtime season ticket holder for the
Women's Basketball team so I guess I
qualify they're uh not one of the top
programs in the country country so that
certainly shows at least some support
for for women's sports um best my
knowledge there's never been a trans
athlete either on our team and and the
opponent's team but it is certainly
common place for uh common place for for
men to be participating either as
coaches um some teams including the UNH
team sometimes we have practice players
who come in and practice in the morning
to you know round out the squads so they
can do different types of um so um the
whole thing with the locker rooms that's
an issue they already uh deal with
because there there's already male
participants in female sports at the
Collegiate level in the high school
level there's already like female
participants in the college sports both
as players and also as trainers de
casely as coaches
um they um I probably should have
mentioned uh of the UNH Women's
Basketball team I should have mentioned
our state champion uh oyer River girls
track team which apparently won what was
the most important sporting event at
least According to some people not just
for the participants for some people who
weren't participants are very up uh
concerned about it um what the division
2 indoor girls track Championship which
has uh been that subject a lot
apparently that's bigger even than the
division one Championship or even the
Super Bowl which is on the same day and
it certainly was for the participants I
believe we have a participant off from
Oyster River in the room so
congratulations to everyone who
participated whether they want uh so
this band's biological males I'm not
sure why being a biological male should
Trump what your gender identity is um
from participating in you know just
about any school or college Bo just
actually includes even the private
schools who merely happen to have
students who to wish the subsidized by
the EFA School Voucher Program some of
whom are even from from out of state so
your two minutes are up okay so I just
think this bill is cruel and unnecessary
this should be left to the sanctioning
bodies and in any case um being a trans
but you know being being trans is very
very difficult um it's it's one the most
difficult things person can do and I
don't think anybody is doing it just to
unfairly win you know a Track medal or
even a scholarship most women's
scholarships are only partial most col
scholarships any sports especially women
sports us only partial scholarship so
it's a lot of trouble to go to just for
a partial scholarship nobody's doing it
just for that and they're participating
the sport for the same reason uh CIS CIS
mail sis men and CIS women support
because they love the sport so I was I
would just say itl no I can also I'm
spending my time here two minutes up
repres the reason this bill the Senate
bills were actually like more extensive
one of the reasons they they left things
out of the Senate bill is because the
Senate rejected those things your time
is up oh thank you of course yes yes
we'll have to unpack in two minutes
questions from the
committee thank you very
hello my name is Lind J house I oppose
this bill there is no reason to change
the New Hampshire inter Scholastic
Athletic Association policy that
includes transgender athletes I'd like
to read excert from testimony provided
by a few people who could not be here
today but first transgender athletes
vary in athletic ability just like
non-transgender athletes one high jumper
could be tall and have longer legs than
another but the other could have perfect
form and then do better explains Andrea
Yearwood a student track athlete one
Sprinter could have parents who spend so
much money on personal training for
their child which in Cur which in turn
could cause that child to run
faster in Connecticut where U
non-transgender girl runners have tried
to block Andrea from participating in
the sport she loves the very same girls
who have claimed that trans athletes
have an quote unquote unfair Advantage
have consistently performed as well as
or better than their transgender
competitors overwhelmingly we do not
question girls who are assigned female
at Birth although some of them may be
significantly taller or vary in hormone
levels um or due to other um from other
girls for example Runner Caster Sania
who is assigned female at Birth despite
having XY chromosomes um who is interx
but identifies as a woman was still made
to undergo sex testing before being
cleared to play so if this bill were to
pass it would ow for the questioning of
gender non-conforming women who were
signed female at Birth and identify as
women a person's genetic makeup and
internal and external reproductive
Anatomy are not useful indicators of
athletic performance according to Dr
Joshua D safer for transwoman athlete
who meets NCAA standards there is no
inherent reason why her physiological
characteristics related to athletic
performance should be treated
differently from a non-transgender
women um those of you who are on this
committee have likely heard from Lane
Rin previously a now 19-year-old
transgender woman who played High School
soccer with other girls throughout high
school she says my closest friends
played soccer with me in middle school
and throughout High School no one had a
problem with me being transgender I
guarantee that no one on the opposing
teams even had any idea that I am
transgender after I came out I was
treated like all the other girls in
every part of school in the classroom in
the art studio on the theater stage and
on the soccer fi your time is up thank
you are there any questions from the
committee now seeing thank you very
much uh
Roger hello right you yeah you did
better than your first
card I was going to rush I
guess yes um my name is Roger blow I'm a
Vietnam Veteran New Hampshire lifelong
resident married 53 years to my
sweetheart um the thing I want to talk
about is this transgender stuff I have a
transgender grandson and he's doing very
well and I'm going to tell you he went
through a lot the trans the transition a
lot of family members went down to
Boston to professionals and talked about
it because we wanted to make sure as a
teenager he wasn't just you know being
uh difficult or you know trying to re
you know reach out to to get his parents
upset uh but they determined that he
really feels in his in his true self his
identity is that he's a boy and so so
he's transitioned so he has a beard etc
etc and he's doing very well um I asked
him uh what I should comment he said I I
mean I think the big thing would be
talking about how everyone's hormone
levels are different and when trans
people take hormones that is monitored
and kept within a normal range for their
age so theoretically there is no
difference in skill Advantage between
trans and cisgender people I get blood
blood work done to make sure my
testosterone levels aren't too high or
too low which is also something that s
gender men can do as well as testing
astrogel for women so basically the
medical profession people deal with this
at the time that he transgendered uh
they were he was the 1500 person in this
Boston hospital that did that and he's
very happy uh before he did that he was
not feeling comfortable with himself and
he really needed it I really believe by
the way I coach Sports a lot my three
children five grandchildren all played a
lot of sports and uh there's injuries
all the time and the injuries that I
seen they're all girl and girls it's not
you know a transgender person doing it
my granddaugh plays rugby pli broke her
leg last year my other daughter that
plays hockey potential girl on the team
broke her ankle it was no transgender
person trying to hurt them etc etc so I
think what rep representative Milo said
is the best thing there are so many
transgender people that will benefit
from allowing them to play compared to
the few people that feel that oh it's
unfair to the other girls I think that's
at the best point a lot of people
benefit your time is up okay thank you
thank you are there any questions from
the committee thank you very much uh
Jennifer
black good
afternoon thank you for allowing me to
speak my name is Jennifer black and I
live in Windam I come here as a former
female student athlete and the mom of
three female student athletes I'm here
and Court of SB
375 when I was seven I went to my first
Red Sox game and right then and there I
decided my destiny was to be a major
league Red Sox player I informed my mom
and dad and the only thing they told me
was that I had to practice practice
practice so I did things went well for a
while I was chosen to be the only girl
on the Little League All-Star team and
later was the only girl in the local
Babe Ruth league then I went to high
school what do you mean I have to play
softball I asked if I could play
freshman boys baseball and to their
credit the coach and principal said yes
yes so I joined the team but it became
disappointingly clear very quickly that
I would not be playing in the major
leagues the boys seemingly overnight had
become much faster stronger and taller I
realized I was literally out of my
league I made the difficult decision to
switch to fast pitch softball we were a
good team winning the state championship
my junior year and Runners up my senior
year despite the fact that we were state
champions had any one of those freshman
boys decided to play on the varsity
girls softball team his ability would
have surpassed the best varsity girls
player on our team have you noticed that
this is mostly a one-way street with
individuals born boys seeking to play on
a team made up of individuals born as
girls these individuals would take an
opportunity purposely carved out for
girls and young women who until
relatively recently traditionally had
few to no options to play sports to
allow individuals born as boys to play
girls Sports will necessarily reduce
opportunities for women to play and
Excel in far in hard fought for Le of
their own now I'd like to speak as a mom
of female athletes last year my girls
were in a volleyball league were an
opposing team at a 6'2 in individual
born as a male play on the girls team
our girls coach was concerned for the
safety of her team most of the girls
were 55 or under and instructed them to
get out of the way and give the other
team the point when this individual Was
preparing to spike the ball thank God no
one was hurt and our school subsequently
made the difficult decision to pull out
of the league because the school didn't
want to put the girls in physical Danger
this individual has been since been
documented to have hurt opposing female
players while playing against them in
other sports your time is up okay what
sum summing up women fought long and
hard to have athletic teams of their own
to allow individuals born as boys to
take those opportunities from girls and
women and to put women back women and
girls in physical danger due to their
size strength and speed would be turning
back the clock to a time when women were
sidelined with their only option to
cheer on the men I ask you to stand up
for women and girls by supporting this
Bill thank you thank you very much there
any questions from the
committee not see thank
you Michelle
vessie
Daisy Michelle
here okay going on to Sarah
good afternoon esteemed committee
members and thank you for taking your
time and attention to discuss s SP 375
with us my name is Sarah Terrell I'm a
resident of Plymouth New Hampshire in
District 5 and I am a parent of a
transgender athlete I implore you to
consider the profound impact this bill
will have on my daughter and countless
others in the state I understand the
Allure of succumbing to is the
sensationalized narrative surrounding
transgender athletes however I urge you
to rise above the fear-driven rhetoric
and instead heed the guidance of medical
and mental health experts who advocate
for inclusive Sports environments we
have a petition to share with you today
that is signed by almost 200 women
athletes across the state of New
Hampshire who have voiced their support
for their transgender teammates
underscoring the importance of
solidarity and inclusion in our athletic
communities it's disheartening to
witness the disproportionate focus on
such a small subset of student athletes
in our state for nearly a decade
existing rules and policies set by the
nhaa that allow transgender girls to
play on girls teams have effectively
governed transgender participation in
sports without incident injuries and
unfairness are not rampant on our fields
on our tracks or our courts due to
transgender athletes if safety is a
genuine concern then
let's direct our efforts towards
meaningful initiatives such as increased
funding for athletic trainers on site
enhanced coaching and referee training
and perhaps even improved Pro concussion
protocols discriminating against a
marginalized group of student athletes
serves no purpose other than to inflict
unnecessary harm on girls like my
daughter who should be able to
participate in every aspect of daily
life as who she is including on the
soccer field I implore you to prioritize
fairness inclusivity and evidence-based
decision-making in your deliberations
over SB 375 let's work together to
ensure the safety and well-being of all
students athletes regardless of their
gender thank you for your attention in
this thank you very much other questions
from the
committee thank you thank
related good afternoon morning uh my
name is Parker trell and I am a
15-year-old freshman at Plymouth
Regional High School like many teenagers
I have loving family I enjoy spending
time with friends and playing video
games however there's a key part of who
I am that I want to share with you I'm
transgender I'm here today to express my
deep concern regarding SB 375 and S and
similar legislative efforts aimed at
barring transgender students like me
from participating in sports despite
just being a regular teenager with a
passion for soccer I found myself facing
the threat of exclusion simply because
of who I am let me be clear I am not a
physical threat to peers on the field on
the field nor do I seek any unfair
Advantage by playing on a girl sports
team I play soccer because I love the
sport the camaraderie and the
opportunity to grow as an athlete even
if we don't win a game my coach sh takes
us to KFC after an away game taking over
the restaurant yeah taking over the
restaurant with my team is one of my
favorite memories from this past soccer
season it is disheartening to see
lawmakers pushing for discriminatory me
measures without taking any without
taking any time to understand the real
impact it has on students like me why my
safety any less important to that of my
peers claims that I should play on the
team based on my assigned gender of
Earth completely disre disregard the
very real risks I would face on a boy
soccer team it's not just about the
risks I can't play on a boy team because
I am not a boy I am a girl my safety
well-being and sense of belonging matter
just as much as anyone else's I'm
fortunate to have the support of my
family friends teammates coach and
school Community as well as the
countless athletes across the state who
recognize the rhetoric but o
recognize the importance of exclusion
and acceptance I urge you not to be
swayed by the discriminatory rhetoric
but to stand on the right side of
History supporting all students
regardless of their gender in pursuing
and passions and dreams thank you for
your time and consideration sincerely
Parker trell thank you very much yes
representative
spear I Want to Thank You for Your brave
testimony and I wish you all the luck in
the world thank you so are there any
other are there questions from the
committee Yes representa W talk good
afternoon how you doing thank thank you
for coming um in your your you're
playing freshman soccer now we were
fa yes okay did you did you have any
issues or any other teams you're playing
with no so during the during the course
of your playing soccer enjoying soccer
and the women's soccer team there
another the issue any other team you
played with what sorry there no other
issue on any other team no thank you
yeah further questions from the
Trumble
be thank you Mr chairman my name is
David Trumble and I'm a opposed to this
bill for a few reasons first the
language in this bill is incredibly
disrespectful it refers to transgender
women as men if a transgender woman
serves in the United States Army they
get to serve as the gender they identify
with but if that person comes home and
goes to UNH and decides to run track
they're no longer a Woman by the words
of this bill they have now become a man
this is incredibly disrespectful
language second this bill is
inconsistent with all of the major
athletic organizations the international
Olympic committee's policy is based on
safe inclusive and an equitable
environment and based on evidence it's
the same three criteria that Senator
Lang came up with but the ioc does not
ban transgender women from competing in
female sports they use the same criteria
to come to a different conclusion the
NCAA does not ban transgender women from
competing in fact they have said that if
States pass laws like this they won't be
able to host NCAA tournaments and then
at the local level of New Hampshire you
have the nhiaa policy global national
and state level all of the international
all of the athletic organizations say
this proposed bill doesn't match let's
look at the
evidence the Journal sports medicine did
a study and they looked at all of the
the literature on this and they
concluded there is no direct or
consistent research suggesting
transgender female athletes have an
athletic advantage at any stage of their
transition the majority aity of sports
policies unfairly exclude trans people
from competitive sport the Canadian
Center for ethic Sports said there's no
firm basis available in evidence to
indicate trans women have a consistent
and measurable overall performance
benefit after 12 months of testosterone
supression Senator Lang cited the
American collegey of sports medicine but
their report said quote does not make
any policy recommendations which are
outside the scope of his purpose so it's
a misstatement to suggest that that
study should be used to make policy but
you have other that suggest there is no
competitive Advantage thank you thank
you very much are there questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you Mr chairman mail
Jacks
Jack good morning or I suppose at this
point afternoon um as education
committee my name is my jacqu a
16-year-old s from Newbury and I'm here
to testify in opposition of s SP
375 throughout my entire life Sports
have been an integral part to My
belonging playing playing soccer since
the age of three when I began my
transition in the sixth grade my school
welcomed me onto the girls team this act
of being able to be a part of the teams
I belonged to allowed me to skip through
the phase of social ostracization as the
other girls accepted me for who I was
and welcomed me especially by their
locker room rituals like the ones where
we go around and give a word of how we
wanted to perform that game being part
of the team allowed me to be seen as
normal or everywhere else I could be
perceived as a pariah I didn't join
sports with the goal of dominating
competition or being better than anyone
else no one would go through the
bullying and self-hatred of transition
purely to win a sport especially women's
sports which are underappreciated in our
nation I joined because it's something
I'm passionate about and enjoy if banned
from sports teams and locker rooms
joining the mail teams wouldn't even be
a choice for me with the and threats I'd
receive let alone the mental anguish i'
go through being forced to be someone
I'm not thank you for your consideration
and please vote in opposition to SV 375
sincerely my sh thank you are there any
questions from the committee not see any
thank you yes represent wicock thank you
good afternoon how you doing good thank
you for waiting around I know side at 11
o' this morning um just just a question
in your participation in sports uh have
you had any other teams complain or ask
you to leave or stop the game never I've
all the other teams have been very
supportive the only
um problems I've received are from
outside parties like media sources and
whatnot I've never received anything
negative from other teams and coaches
and players athletes are athletes right
thank you thank you thank you very much
are there other questions thank you
thank you uh Peter
Hansen Peter here
bitman
no
Brennan oh we
are teacher and I writing on the board
sorry
side I'm from
where quote if you consider yourself a
girl and you want to play sports you
should be able to play that quote comes
from winning South Carolina basketball
coach Dawn Staley these kids are real
every major medical and mental Health
Association supports transgender people
and acknowledges their truth but it's
hard to hear the truth over the D of
vicious conspiracy theories if everybody
knows that men are men and women are
women as I so often hear what box do we
check for interex people whose physical
characteristics and chromosomes do not
fit the binary and who by the way make
up as large a group as transgender
people people here's another thing that
upsets the binary there are studies that
indicate that before hormones even
transgender female brains have more in
common than
cisgender with cisgender female brains
than with male brains the report fair
play details the benefits and as they
say transgender youth are already
vulnerable Banning them from Sports
further legitimizes trans trans phobic
attitudes there are dozens of these
bills and yet there are so few students
one report I read and all these are
footnoted in your copy one report I read
said that as of a year ago there might
be only 100
transgender girls playing sports in high
schools across this country and yet
there's so much outrage why aren't we
outraged that the top WNBA pick female
is only being offered
$76,000 while the top male is being
offered 105 million why aren't we
outraged by the girls um swim teams and
Gymnastic teams that we heard about
where the coaches were abusing them
those are the things we should be
outraged about not about this Sports
aren't Fair they aren't we're different
sizes different abilities different
coaching and for every team of 10 fully
cisgender girls there are two three four
five six seven cisgender girls that
don't make it it has nothing to do with
a trans kid on the
team I would
say that the ultimate in
unfairness is othering and erasing this
very small group of kids who just want
to play and I stand with this coach and
she stands with these kids and I am so
won okay uh any questions from the
committee
yes th this bill wants to uh establish
um I guess sexual identity at down to
the sixth grade it doesn't apply below
sixth grade fifth grade or below at
sixth grade at least from my memory and
I would like to know from your
experience uh kids are very undeveloped
at that point at sixth grade the thing
that they need to learn more than they
probably need to learn anything else is
social interactions and how to be team
members and all that sort of
thing this bill seeks to take that away
what is your experience as a teacher in
noting the ability of sixth graders for
instance uh to be outed you know made
into other made made into
uh I don't know what it called
marginalized individuals yeah it's it's
terrible I taught Middle School I taught
high school and uh what happens to these
kids and in my experience um it was more
often gay kids that were outed and it is
cruel it is awful and need to be
teaching kindness and support and
inclusivity and not othering little
groups um Chris
kristopherson has a song that one of the
lines is and he talks about all the
groups that are against each other and
he says cuz everybody's got to have
somebody to look down on and that's how
I feel when I hear the hate directed
against these children it really bothers
mothers me any further questions from
the committee thank you very much thank
Bata thank you I'm Laura Bata from
Hudson um my interest in this primarily
my I guess my insight as a former public
school student um is the locker room
angle um we are in New New England I
want to reference back I believe it was
uh roughly around 2002 plus or minus a
little bit I was a high school student
and I read in the Hartford current about
males seeking these new ID changes and I
being an intelligent person reading
science fiction reading history I saw oh
male ID changes to to an X or to an F
Well that that would let them in the
locker room and way back then I asked
the adults in my life I said what if all
this goes through I said I'm not going
to school I am not taking my clothes off
in front of biological men no matter
what their identification says I said if
something like this goes through I will
refuse school you'll have to homeschool
me so today seeing what has happened
what would have been called utter
Madness
not so many years ago I am here to stand
up for the girls whatever girls who say
gee I want to play sports but I guess I
got to put up with so and so in in the
locker room and maybe they're looking at
me or the girls who say oh I'm scared
off about this I'm just not going to
play sports how many girls have are are
are in that situation overall there has
been a chilling effect on Free Speech I
do not believe that people feel free to
say how they really feel what will their
college say what will their future
employer say I am asking you to take a
sober approach to basic Common Sense
girls shouldn't be taking their clothes
off in front of biological males for any
opportunity thank you thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee thank you uh Christina can
scar hi I'm best scare from nashwa um I
just wanted to respond to some earlier
people testifying um representative cig
um said that heterosexual men are not
trans women a large percentage of trans
women are heter hetosexual and are
sexually attracted to women so that's
just one more reason why they shouldn't
be in our locker rooms it's called
autophilia and the NH responding to uh
Roger I believe it was the nhiaa does
not require any hormones there are no
hormone levels to check there's no
verification that they're doing anything
that the boys are doing anything but
putting on a uniform and claiming to be
girls and as far as Parker's
testimony um Parker is concerned that
it's not safe to play for Parker to play
on a male team well why is it safe for
girls to play with males on their team I
mean it's it it cuts both
ways and I just um I also wanted to say
girls are not being warned about these
boys it's being sprung on them boys you
know naked boys show up in the locker
room that's sexual abuse
why are we allowing this to
happen
um and I I guess that's that's all I
have for today thanks please please vote
um a to pass on S SP 375 thank you very
much are there questions from the
chairman and members of the committee
thanks for your time my name is Devin
Quinn I'm the director of policy for the
New Hampshire women's Foundation where
we invest in equality and opportunity
for the women and girls of New Hampshire
through research education advocacy and
Grant making we respectfully and
adamantly oppose SB 375 because it
discriminates against trans girls who
deserve to be accepted and included in
our SCS in our schools trans girls are
girls period and trans girls like all
girls deserve have to have access to the
many benefits of sports like teamwork
friendship and belonging um we at the
women's Foundation are very concerned
about the youth Mental Health crisis
which is particularly impacting uh girls
in New Hampshire particularly girls um
of the lgbtq community and trans girls
we need more more opportunities and
supports um for all girls not less uh
logistically you've heard before that uh
this bill is inconsistent with
inconsistent with nhia um rules uh
recently enacted non-discrimination laws
and would open the door to violations of
Title 9 um but the women's foundation
and other women's organizations and
sports organizations all support trans
inclusive policies including the
National Women's Law Center the women's
sports foundation and women leaders in
college sport
there are real issues in women's sports
particularly in resources and funding
and at the professional level inadequate
um uh salary and prizes um but student
athletes are not asking for us to ban
their friends from playing and they and
we are asking you to let trans girls
play thank you are there from the
committee any
questions
thank you I you you said something very
quickly and I wanted to just get a
clarification has there been any reports
of any uh girl CIS girls I guess uh
athletes complaining about transgender
kids being on their on their
teams these days girls it's girls want
to play with girls on girls teams when
girls sports are available to them and
trans girls are girls and they are
friends and community members and
students uh and they want to be able to
play with their friends on sports
teams further
Holmes want to give
me thank you for letting me speak you'll
like it that I'll be very quick
Kathy Holmes track
Jester um there should be no need for
this
bill but we are living in a surreal
world where actual science is being
cancelled and social science Rules an
example is when a person can make the
statement trans girls are girls that
goes directly against science actual
science you must judge which issue
carries more weight people people's
feelings about who they are and people
harmed and in danger because of what
goes on in these sporting events and
we've seen it on
TV uh that's all well thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee thank
good afternoon thank you again for my
hearing my testimony today for the
record my name is Emma sinini I'm the
children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that solves problems
through policy change we are dedicated
to supporting and strengthening a
comprehensive system of care for young
children we are here in strong
opposition to Senate Bill 375 because
transgender and non-binary youth deserve
the exact same opportunities to develop
social and emotional skills as their
peers and those skills can be developed
through Sports we all envision of uh New
Hampshire where all students all young
people are able to freely Express
themselves and live without the burdens
of poor mental health however
unfortunately our young people
especially those who identify as trans
are undergoing severe mental health
Health crisis due to feeling
discriminated against when young people
are Fel uh feel supported in their
communities such as through playing
sports with a team they can have higher
and better mental health outcomes and
those that are on par with their
peers similarly all students who
participate in sports are able to get
the social emotional benefits such as
building confidence leadership teamwork
friendships um the list goes on and on
plus exercise increases mental health or
uh benefits mental health as such all
students deserve the right to play
sports regardless of their gender
identity as uh for those reasons new
Futures urges this committee to vote itl
on Senate Bill 375 and I'm happy to take
any questions thank you from the
committee any
questions thank you very much thank
hi there um my name is Aubrey Nelson I'm
from Conquer New Hampshire um thank you
very much uh distinguished members of
the House Education committee for
hearing my
testimony um I'm opposed to Senate Bill
375 I'm an athlete um I'm a pretty good
athlete I I wore my um New Hampshire
three sport athlete I grew up in New
Hampshire
and I'm frankly insulted by this bill
because I'm a woman athlete I've I was
fortunate enough to be born with a
gender that I identify with in terms of
what the doctor said at Birth but I
wanted to speak a little bit to safety
and to science which are both mentioned
here several times I'm also a science
teacher and so I look for evidence in
making decisions and when it comes to
biological sex logically people are all
different nature doesn't stick to
categories that humans have invented
about two in every 100 people are born
with interex traits that means that you
likely know somebody who was born with
an interex trait and a doctor at Birth
is has a has to decide like this is what
this child will be when all they have is
evidence of genitalia which often for
about two and or One in every 200 people
are not clinically identifiable um and
have some kind of VAR
so are we saying that like you can't
belong or be part of a sports team if
you don't fit into these NE categories
that we as human beings have invented
biologically Nature's not neat it's just
not when it comes to safety I think the
real safety risk is having somebody who
would be who is a woman in a men's
locker room if they have if they're not
allowed to use the women's locker room
that to me feels very unsafe especially
for trans women who have been bullied
primarily in my experience in school and
Athletics by men so like forcing a woman
to use a men's locker room because at
Birth when the doctor was looking at
them they made some determination feels
really terrible and the reason I'm
insulted as an athlete is because I want
the chance to compete against the
best I don't want as a woman athlete I
don't if I'm cut from the team that's
cuz I didn't work hard enough or because
some other part of my life like I didn't
make the cut and I want that challenge
you're I want all women to participate
um so yeah I'll take questions if thank
you are there questions from the
committee thank you um I have also a
letter that was signed by about 40 other
athletes that I'll just pass around um
these are other women athletes who would
like to the chance to participate
against all other women athletes you
want that become part of the record
yes please okay fine send it up to us
mine did this come your
way good afternoon my name is Michelle
siloy I live in Temple and I'm here in
opposition to SB
375 for as long as I can remember I have
felt more at home more myself when I
have a soccer ball at my feet or while
I'm wearing my running shoes my time as
an athlete is significantly contributed
to the adult I am today as a 5-year-old
soccer player I learned the joys of
teamwork and the importance of
dedication as an 18-year-old Runner I
learned self-discipline and drive I was
recruited and given an athletic
scholarship to continue running at
Northeastern University however my
freshman year I sustained a career-
ending injury while I no longer compete
as an athlete today I still run and Play
Soccer one of the most important lessons
I learned as an athlete was to never
give up perseverance in life brings you
places you may never have dreamed of and
will carry you through times of struggle
now 31 years after graduating high
school I'm a mom of six I'm a mom to a
dancer a former lacrosse player a former
rugby player and three soccer players as
a mother I hope my children learn Grace
the power of community and working as a
team compassion for others empathy
discipline and acceptance while enjoying
their time in
sports as I spoke earlier today this
past year my 17-year-old survived an
attempted suicide due to their gender
dysphoria and severe depression they are
currently receiving Essential Medical
Care to allow their body to be the more
feminine home they feel as their own and
while our journey supporting a trans
teen has been very difficult at times I
can not cannot imagine the added turmoil
a band such as this would bring the
isolation that trans youth Endor is
inconceivable for most separating and
excluding a small group of kids from
their friends and teammates further
exacerbates this isolation supporting
and promoting the blatant discrimination
of transgender athletes is not the way
of the granite state sport should be a
place where we Embrace diversity in
teamm ship trans girls are girls and
they belong playing alongside their
fellow non-transgender female athletes
the relationships a person experiences
through being a part of a sport are
life-changing though few athletes reach
reach the highest level of competition
lessons received through being a part of
a sport are immeasurable to remove an
athlete from a team that has bonded and
created lasting relationships due to
their biological sex negating their true
identity as a trans youth would have a
detrimental effect on all student
athletes I have one more sentence to
consider a trans girls a female during
her school day but exclude her from
joining a school sports team is an
outright denial of her equal educational
opportunities as legislators you need to
prevent and stop the repercussions of
this bill please vote itl for SP 375
thank you very much uh from the
committee are there any
questions thank
you thank
you uh
rousan
Chester thank you committee chair thank
you committee members my name is Russ
anchester Bedford New Hampshire um many
years ago I was very supportive of girls
can do anything boys can do um I was
very involved with the feminist movement
equal rights for equal pay etc etc um I
grew up in a small town where 4 fo8 I
wasn't playing basketball 4 fo8 I
probably wasn't going to run anywhere
fast these hand F at when I was younger
weren't going to handle a
softball so I wanted to play football um
fortunately we had a pop warner team and
I was able to play football because boys
and girls can play together there's no
locker room issue there's no and Bullies
of bullies um it was based on weight and
age and all of
that because I grew up that way when I
went to high school here in New
Hampshire I wanted to play football I
wanted to try out for the football team
and I was told I could not because I was
born female I fought it I won I tried
out I made the team well let's take that
back I did not make the team first round
and then I brought it up that I felt
that I was being discriminated against
because I was a lot better than a lot of
the boys that made the team so they did
a blind
redo um and I made the
team I played freshman
year I was pretty good um even my coach
had the but my coach said to me I have
to pay for all my own equipment cuz we
don't have that in the budget for girls
girls equipment's different than boys
equipment so trans girls on a football
team would have to use different
equipment if unless they've had
alterations um and the bottom line is is
that so I knew that I would have that I
was on a team with all boys except for
me when my coach um when my coach
accepted that I was going to be on his
team he called a team meeting and he
said we only have one locker room
available we're not opening the girls
room just for you figure it out um and
we worked with the guys um on my team
and we were able to come to the
conclusion that your time is up yes just
very quickly we were able to come to the
conclusion that that we could all work
together and mutually respect one
another um this is not an easy task but
at the same time by sophomore year I
realized that it was not appropriate for
me to be playing football at a high
school level and I took myself off the
team um but I do understand um the folks
here back then no one would have known
girl and that's the most important part
of this is that we're discriminating
based on what we're telling people we
are your time is up yeah thank you are
there any
testerman yeah oh there we go my name is
Holloway testerman I'm here in
opposition of this bill um and uh the
sponsor that uh introduced this bill um
seemed to be pretty concerned about um
safety and I think I have some pretty
similar concerns um and I guess my main
question is how are we going to
implement this bill because we know that
um paperwork identification paperwork um
the the gender marked there doesn't
always match the sex assigned birth
right um we heard from uh someone else
who testified that blood test hormone
levels aren't always going to tell us
what um someone's sex assigned at Birth
is um and I I think genetic testing
raises some ethical concerns that this
bill doesn't isn't really able to cover
um so are we going to ask athletes about
their periods because um not all girls
have regular periods right um are we
going to do physical examinations CU
that seems really invasive and traumatic
I mean all of these things seem super
invasive and traumatic but um I guess my
concern here is yes this is about uh you
know contrary to what the sponsor who
introduced this Bill said this is about
um not allowing Tren kids in sports um
but it seems to me that this bill is
really about controlling women's bodies
all women's bodies regardless of whether
they are trans or cisgender because you
cannot tell someone is trans by looking
at them um so
this this bill is an expedient because
there's no way to implement it um it is
simply there to cause discrimination and
so fear um thank you thank you are there
any questions from the
committee thank you very much uh Kate
mccardy
hello again my name is Kate mccardy uh
I'm here to oppose SB 375 my daughter's
best friend plays field hockey uh this
past season she got bulldozed by an
opposing team member and broke her
collar bone ending her season that
opposing team member was a cisgender
girl my future daughter-in-law was
injured badly in her senior year on the
field hockey field by another cisgender
girl there will always be stories about
sports injuries and almost all of them
are incurred through contact with
another cisgender girl I just have
quotes from a couple of entities that
are directly involved with the subject
the women's sports Foundation supports
the right of all athletes including
transgender athletes to participate in
athletic competition that is fair
Equitable and respectful to all
transgender refers to people whose
gender identity their internal sense of
themselves as male or female does not
conform to traditional expectations
associated with their assigned sex at
Birth schools must be prepared to fairly
accommodate these students and their
families in athletics as well as other
school programs the nhiaa has asserted
since 2015 that all girls should be
allowed to participate in girl Sports
including transgender girls when did it
become common practice to disregard
expert opinions and act on emotion and
Prejudice we need to do better and since
I have a few more seconds I find it very
telling that a certain person here
didn't miss jender Parker the way she
did in the hallway while shoving a phone
camera in her face against her parents
wishes thank you are there any questions
from the committee
gs hi thank you so much for taking the
time to hear my testimony again uh for
the record my name is Courtney Reid I
serve as policy Advocate at the ACLU of
New Hampshire uh and we oppose this bill
um you we' already heard from another
civil rights uh attorney that um there
are many reasons to vote down this bill
um one being that uh in numerous cases
uh legislation that categorically bars
transgender people from participating in
sports that aligns with their gender is
not only
unconstitutional violating equal
protections under the law but also was
in violation of Title 9 and that just
last week there were several actions or
updates to the law to strengthen Title 9
protections for transgender individuals
that being uh the ruling from the fourth
circuit uh opposing a very similar bill
on the grounds that exclusion of uh
Sports participation is violation of
title n uh as well as additional
guidelines from the Department of
Education um to elaborate that uh on
that a little bit more there have also
been some cases uh in state courts such
as Arizona that have ruled uh
categorical prohibition of participation
for transgender students violate um
state constitutions or in New
Hampshire's instance there's also uh
state laws that we passed with
bipartisan support only a few years ago
uh that offer protections based on
gender identity um and that compel
schools to create policies to prevent
and intervene in Acts of
discrimination we've also heard a little
bit about how unworkable this bill would
be is it up to coaches or teachers to
ensure and certify that the birth
certificates or the enforcement
mechanism behind this bill are true and
that they actually don't you know match
the uh the gender of a trans student and
what liabilities do they face if they
make a mistake uh I think there are some
serious privacy concerns that uh the ACL
you would like to raise and I'm happy to
take some questions about the benefits
um in Public Health Data that we have
around uh what it means to allow
transgender students to play sports
thank you very much other questions from
the
committee thank you very much thank you
hi my name is Stephanie Lebec and I'm
alumni of the POU State Varsity women's
swim team and Club Ultimate Frisbee team
and I am a resident of Waterville Valley
I will be reading a petition on behalf
of women athletes in which over 178 New
Hampshire residents have signed in
opposition to SB
375 to The Honorable elected officials
of the New Hampshire State Legislature
we the under assigned women athletes of
New Hampshire are writing to stress our
opposition to S SP 375 SB 524 and HB
1205 in all bills that would diminish
inclusivity in sports by prohibiting
transgender athletes by playing at New
Hampshire schools clubs or colleges and
universities transgender athletes belong
in sports with cisgender female athletes
they should have the right to
participate on teams that align with
their gender is codified by Title 9 in
New Hampshire's own transgender
non-discrimination law it is wrong to
deprive someone of all that Sports offer
our young people as they develop into
responsible adults solely because of
their gender as athletes we recognize
that our dedication practice and hard
work are Paramount to our successes all
girls deserve the opportunity to be
respected members of sports teams as
athletes ourselves we cannot stay silent
while members of our community are
discriminated against these bills would
needlessly divide teammates Force
college athletic administrations to
police the gender of visiting student
athletes and restrict competition by
discouraging other colleges and
universities from coming to New
Hampshire they would also exacerbate the
mental health challenges impacting
student athletes needless to say this
would devalue New Hampshire's athletic
programs are Collegiate recruiting
opportunities and diminish the level of
competition for all colle Collegiate
athletic programs in the state the New
Hampshire inter Scholastic Athletic
Association has determined in its policy
that it would be fundamentally unjust to
ban transgender athletes from
participation when when Governor suu
signed discrimination protections into
law he wrote that it was important that
New Hampshire is a place where every
person regardless of their background
has an equal and full opportunity to
pursue their dreams and to make better
lives for themselves and their families
these bills seek to undermine these
values transgender athletes are
teammates peers competitors and Friends
their participation strengthens all of
us for the benefit of our student
athletes schools and integrity of
competition we encourage you to reject
these harmful and divisive bills in any
other that restrict the rights of
transgender student athletes sincerely
Amanda Allard Franklin former swim coach
at Mount Washington Valley Dolphins Andy
Allison student athlete UNH soccer
Addison alers Bristol your your time is
up okay um are there any questions from
the committee thank
is that for the
record um it's just a
this song oh there we
go so my name is Masha Gaba and I live
in Manchester New
Hampshire all our son wanted to do was
fit in and not be
rejected he could not bear any more
hurt please consider no more hurting
people that's a quote from Martin
Boston thank you are there any questions
from the committee not seeing thank you
very
thank you chairman lad members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today it's been a long day I'll keep my
comments brief uh my name is Sam Hawkins
I'm the public policy assistant at Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness the record Nami New
Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I'm here today to
speak in opposition to Senate Bill
375 Nami New Hampshire believes that
freedom from stigma and discrimination
is crucial to mental Wellness in part
our mental health reflects our
environments and the conditions in which
we live who and what we interact with
how we're treated and whether we can
live as our authentic selves as such it
should be our priority to ensure that
everyone within our communities is
accepted and able to live fully in
accordance with their identities free
from stigma and
discrimination this is crucial to all
aspects of Life at home at work school
and in one's interests and Endeavors
including athle Athletics where
individuals in this case youth learn to
express themselves and connect with our
peers in community Senate Bill 375
furthers damaging stigma for transgender
Youth and limits access to affirming
environments by prohibiting girls from
participating in girl Sports putting
their mental health at risk it is
crucial that our policies promote mental
wellness and create accepting affirming
environments rather than limit them for
these reasons Nami New Hampshire urges
the committee to vote itl for Senate
Bill 375 than thank you are there
questions from the committee not see you
thank you very
much Deborah
house
yes okay good afternoon members of House
Education committee chairman lad good to
see you again uh I am here on behalf of
the American Federation teachers New
Hampshire and our 3700 members across
the state um we are K through2 Educators
University uh faculty and um parents
grandparents and taxpayers in the grant
State and I'm here in opposition to uh
Senate Bill
375 AF New Hampshire stands in
opposition to this bill because in order
for students to become successful in
school they need to feel safe welcome
and they belong in their public schools
in order to do that they have to find
the place where they belong for some
student to uh academics and the math
team debate team for other students it's
music and chorus drama and for some it's
Sports in sports they learn uh physical
skills agility teamwork and find those
relationships with their peers and to
deny that to some of our students
because of who they are is just plain
wrong that's not what our public schools
are about
um so you know the uh sponsor of this
bill claimed it was about F fundamental
Fair and a very simple bill but when you
consider this bill you also need to
consider the unintended consequences
it's not so simple as just looking at a
birth certificate and saying you have to
live that way for the rest of your life
because that is not the truth for some
of our
students um I will tell you just a few
quick points here a policy very similar
to this bill was in place in Texas in
2017 and because a student had to
compete under the gender that was on his
birth
certificate a high school male had to
wrestle um in the girls wrestling
championship and actually won the state
championship in his weight class so if
you're talking about trying to keep
things fair and saving women's sports
keep that in mind um you you may doing
something you didn't intend I have two
more quick points would violate Title
Nine okay because we have to have equal
opportunity for boys and for girls if
you have a girls field hockey team and
you're saying boys can't play on that
team you're now violating Title 9 if
you're saying they can't even try out if
this bill passes and uh beyond that uh
even discussing bands like this
encourages bigotry and hatred there was
an incident out in Utah this winter
where uh a parent was insisting that a
girl on the junior varsity team was a
trans player and got very riled up
despite the fact that the coach the girl
herself and the parents were insisting
no this is a girl playing on a girl's
Team every time we have one of these
bills and have to come out and have
hearings justifying the right of
students to be who they are and play
sports on the team they belong on it
encourages this kind of bigotry um so
when you start separating students
segregating them based on certain
characteristics and saying they cannot
participate in activities in our schools
and and on our sports
teams what we're doing is encouraging
discrimination we should not be going
back to any form of separate but not
equal so we oppose this bill and we urge
you to find an exp to legislate and I'll
be IM meing my testimony thank you thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee not see any thank you very
much and with that I have no further
pink cards on it so I'm going to close
about
for all those in the room we are going
into caucus right now we will be coming
back following caucus to look at the
seven
bills um and and exact those bills later
on today we may or may not exect them
all but we do have at least two bills
here which are early bills which have to
be out of this committee by midweek
today this week they are going to a
second committee so any Bill going to
Second committee has to be out of here
by
Wednesday so we're going to go into
caucus and we'll be coming back and
e
okay we're going to go ahead and enter
into an executive session
here and the first bill we're going to
this bill is relative to the definition
of disability of speal or special needs
under the child care scholarship
program I'd look to represent beler for
a motion thank you Mr chair I would move
in uh in room study and representative
second so we have a motion made by
representative beler and second by
representa Terry the motion is uh
interim study for S SP 596 represent Bel
we like speak to your motion please yes
I'll be brief Mr chair um so we're we're
going to look at interim study on this
bill um because there is some legitimate
question as to whether there might be
some children who were not adequately
able to receive services that that they
should be receiving um right now in
terms of Early Childhood care but the
bill
itself um is very broad somewhat
nebulous uh and needs to be considerably
more narrowly tailored to address this
real concern if it is in fact a real
problem and that that itself needs a
little bit of Investigation as well and
because this is a uh a fiscal Bill we
need to act on it uh early which means
the best we can do right now with it
inter study let's try to fix it and
you okay uh
representative made a second any
discussion or yes I would just say in
addition there was there was
considerable uh conversation in the
caucus around uh the question of there
not needing to be a uh a medical
diagnosis and we'd really like to drill
down on that a little bit and get some
greater specificity how uh
determinations are going to be made and
and by who and on what basis thank you
thank you further discussion
represent represent
Damon thank you so uh we will be
opposing the interm study recommendation
we think that the the Child Care
community and the organizations who
testified on this bill have already done
the work that needs to be done early
quality child care benefits families and
children we should be going forward with
this and I won't spend time saying more
Is there further
discussion mam chair would you please
call the rooll the motion is interim
study
596 Vice chair
Pell yes present
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative gagy yes representative
cortiella yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Corman no
representative Luna no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Alon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
representative spear
no chairman lad yes 10 y 10 y okay the
motion fails uh is there another motion
OTP okay we have a motion by represent
Miler uh OTP and second by
representative
Damon move to the vote please represent
Damon okay uh mam chair when you're
ready would you please call the
roll uh Vice chair
Pell no
Representative
leus no Representative elure no
representative dry no representative
McDonald
yes representative Noble no
Representative gagy
no Representative corello no
representative Terry
no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Corman yes representative
Luna yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes yes
representative
albone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
no oh 11 11 y nine n okay the motion
passes you'll be writing
the
okay okay uh
next bill which we're going to take up
219 and I Look to represent leas for a
motion I move
OTP
pel yes I second
that represent leus would you like to
speak to your motion SV 2119 is Bill
requiring mandatory reporting by school
districts of school expenses yes I would
um a number of the things in here might
already be in
places um potentially even most if not
all of them but they are not easy to
find and the public who votes for these
things needs to actually know what's
going on and so this is part of
transparency for the voters to be able
to have it in one place where they can
find it or three places but in a place
where it's easy for them to find instead
of having to look through all these
different things which they don't even
know where they are to try to find and I
know some of these I tried to find for a
constituent one time and I couldn't find
all of them because there was a
three-letter code that I didn't know
what it was at the time and
so I think voters should be able to have
easy access to this
information that's why I support it
thank you further discussion for the
second no thank
you further discussion from the
committee
represent sorry um there is no need for
this bill number one it could be just a
link to the doe because all the
information is there also um anyone
who's interested in their Town expenses
or School expenses all they need to do
is go to the budget committee meetings
and all of this is already published no
need
further
discussion okay we're going to move into
the uh uh motion now the motion is uh
219 this is a bill relative to reporting
by school districts of school expenses
Madam clerk Vice chair
Pell yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative gagy yes representative
cor yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Corman no
representative Luna no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
representative spear no chairman that
yes 10 y 10 Y is there a motion yes
move to itl Second motion made by
representative cascaden itl and second
by representative
Miler we're talking SB 219
representative
cascaden care to speak I think I've said
what I needed to say thank you represent
mil please
vote okay Madam
clerk did you have oh did have something
to say oh go ahead yes I just wanted to
say that it's it's really good for those
towns that do have budget committees and
do have places where it's easy to find
but that is not true of all towns and
the person who came to me for help was
specifically asking because she couldn't
find it in her town because not all
transparent further
discussion Madam clerk I shair peternell
no Representative leus no Representative
belshire no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
gagy no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Corman yes representative
Luna yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representa
spear yes chairman lab no 10
10 okay who's going to the report okay
gas Cen and uh
it okay the other bills which we had
there specifically sb217 will be held
o'clock one o'clock tomorrow and we'll
be doing the other bills as well at that
time it says 10:15 in the calendar that
doesn't matter that we're meeting trying
to get some amendments made
um the the calendar okay we'll meet at
10:00 we'll meet at
10:00 okay I think we should be able to
done it's kind of rush things but yeah
okay is there anything else for the
committee
okay information about the amendments
yet we we they're they've been sent over
to legislative
Services